The committee will come to order. Thank
you. And the chair will recognize
himself for five minutes for an opening
statement. And good morning and I want
to thank everyone for attending today's
markup. We're taking up several bills
that highlight the committee's effort to
support energy innovation, cut burdens
to red tape, and lower costs for
hardworking Americans. We know that
success for the nuclear industry, from
the fuels, the manufacturers and
reactors to the operators and workers,
will be essential for long-term American
technological leadership globally and
for reliable and abundant energy here at
home. We must strive to return to a pace
of nuclear expansion that surpasses
other nations. And we must do so in a
way that strengthens public confidence
in American technology. This morning,
we're considering six nuclear- related
bills. The bill on the bipartisan
reforms we started two years ago with
the advance act
with improved nuclear permitting brought
the benefits of nuclear energy to f to
Americans faster maintain our commitment
to safety. The bills before us today
clarify pay authority, improve
transparency, eliminate unnecessary
atomic energy act requirements to ensure
licensing runs more smoothly. The
continued bipartisan work on nuclear
policy reflects well on this committee's
ability to advance critical energy
policies and we'll see that bipartisan
spirit reflected in several of the
amendments to the bills before us today
and all of these bills disturb strong
bipartisan support. We are examining
legislation that will provide needed
updates to the Clean Air Act. Outdated
provisions in the law have contributed
counter created counterintuitive and
burdensome policies that increase costs
and negatively impact quality of life
across this country. These are common
sense solutions. The bills before us
will cover a range of issues, including
ensuring that the federal government
retains the authority to regulate
interstate commerce on our nation's
railways, preventing one state from
being able to dictate policy for the
rest of the nation, and reauthorizing a
successful grant program to help us help
bus operators replace old equipment with
new technology. We will also consider a
bill to support the recovery of critical
minerals from domestic sources by
modernizing and streamlining EPA's
regulations of lithium ion batteries,
providing greater clarity and certainty
for our domestic battery recycling
industry. I want to thank all of the
members who have worked so hard to help
bring these important bills before the
committee. I thank all of our committees
and the staff for working hard to bring
uh in almost all areas, not every area,
most areas we agree to agreement and I
really appreciate that and the hard work
and I thank you and I yield to the
ranking member for his opening
statement. I recognize the gentleman
from New Jersey for five minutes.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Today, the full
committee is marking up 10 bills, six
nuclear bills out of our energy
subcommittee and four bills from our
environment subcommittee. Nuclear energy
plays a vital role in our nation's power
grid, providing carbon-f free power to
the grid around the clock. But we must
ensure there is public confidence that
nuclear power is safe and that the cops
on the beat are keeping it safe. And one
of the best ways to ensure that is
through transparency. And I want to once
again state that my support for nuclear
energy legislation is contingent upon
the NRC and the Department of Energy
having sufficient transparency into
their safety rules and regulations so
the American public can be sure that our
nation's nuclear industry is safe. And
that's why I want to compliment Energy
Subcommittee ranking member Caster on
her bill HR9084,
the Department of Energy Nuclear
Transparency Act. It's an important
piece of legislation that will help
build confidence in the American nuclear
industry as a whole as the nation
continues to invest in expanding nuclear
energy. It's critical we have these
important transparency guard rails in
place. I want to thank the chairman and
chairman Guthrie and his staff for their
willingness to work with us on these
nuclear bills. In July, I expressed
concerns about two of the bills before
us today, HR 9612 and HR 9613. on the
Nuclear Advisory Committee Reform Act.
The amendment in the nature of a
substitute strikes a provision from the
introduced bill that would have only
allowed the independent advisory
committee on reactor safeguards to
review and investigate issues if asked
by the NRC. But Chairman Guthri staff
worked diligently with us to find a path
forward that worked for everyone. If the
amendments for those bills are adopted,
I'll support all six nuclear bills on
today's markup. We're also considering
several bills from our environment
subcommittee. HR 9615, the brace act,
will help increase the domestic
recycling batteries and ensure the
critical minerals recovered from those
batteries stay here in the US. And this
is a critical first step to get the EPA
moving on a regulatory framework for
lithium ion battery cycling that
provides certainty for industry and
addresses safety concerns while
maintaining critical protections for the
environment and public health. And this
bill is a compromise. So neither side
got everything they wanted, but I
support this reasonable approach. It's
also not the end of the conversation on
battery recycling, and I look forward to
continuing work across the aisle to
address this growing issue. I'm also
pleased we're considering a bipartisan
reauthorization of the Diesel emissions
reduction act. This long-standing
program helps replace older, dirty
diesel engines across the nation,
cleaning up our air and cutting down on
fuel costs. Unfortunately, I will not be
able to support the remaining bills out
of the Environment Subcommittee. In the
wake of Trump's reckless war of choice
in Iran, Americans are facing a fuel
affordability crisis with diesel prices
over $5 a gallon and gas prices up 30%
compared to last year. American families
are struggling to afford groceries and
school supplies due to high fuel costs
having a devastating ripple effect
throughout the economy. Yet today,
committee Republicans want to move two
bills that would increase fuel use and
health harming and sm and smog forming
pollution and undermine states abilities
to improve air quality and protect
public health. So, the buses act HR 9317
needlessly attacks state policies to
allow school buses and motor coaches to
idle for 15 minutes or longer. This
would allow toxic diesel exhaust to
poison children going to school and
increase fueling costs in the process,
putting a strain on school budgets. And
then there's HR 3194, the Locomotives
Act, which attacks states ability to
control pollution from older, dirtier
locomotives in use today, locking in
this harmful pollution for years to come
and leaving communities and workers to
foot the bill with the hell. So, I'm
going to oppose both of these bills. And
with that, Mr. Chairman, I yield back
the balance of my time.
>> Thank you. The gentleman yields back and
the chair reminds members that pursuant
to the committee rules, all members
opening statements will be made part of
the record. Are there further o further
opening statements? Gentleman from Ohio
is recognized for three minutes for an
opening statement.
>> Well, thank you very much, Mr. Chairman,
and thank you for today's markup.
Today's markup includes six pieces of
legislation improve the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission's licensing
process and the Department of Energy's
nuclear reporting.
These bills uh build on the committee's
bipartisan work to boost momentum for US
nuclear deployment while maintaining
transparency and safety. A robust and
growing American nuclear industry is
vital to meeting growing energy demand
while prioritizing our economic energy
and national security. Last Congress,
this committee's bipartisan efforts led
to the Advance Act, which directed the
NRC to align its mission for enabling
the benefits of nuclear energy. With the
Advance Act, Congress sought an NRC
focusing on efficiency, reducing costs,
and increasing predictability
and the permitting process, all while
maintaining its position as the world's
premier leader in nuclear safety.
The nuclear bills before us today build
upon the Advance Act. The Nuclear Refuel
Act, which I am leading with our
colleague from California's 50th
district, clarifies certain recycling
facilities may be licensed under the
same regulatory framework as other fuel
cycle facilities. This will ensure an
efficient licensing process for
reprocessing and advancing our policy to
maximize access to the additional energy
and isotopes spent in nuclear fuel. Four
other bills before us will amend the
Atomic Energy Act to remove unnecessary
barriers to licensing technologies we
will need for a strong robust nuclear
industry. The American Enrichment
Deployment Act brings the licensing
process for enrichment facilities in
line with the regulatory framework of
the other fuel cycle facilities. The
efficient nuclear's license and hearing
act makes a long overdue change to the
licensing process by removing the
uncontested mandatory hearing and an
outdated requirement which adds time,
cost, and burden without improving
safety or transparency. The nuclear
advisory committee reform act directs
the advisory committee on new reactor
safeguards to focus on issues that are
new, novel in safety. ifi significant.
We expect a bipartisan amendment to
ensure the committee can make more can
the committee can more able implement
this new focus. The NRC staff pay
alignment act builds on the workforce
authorities from the advance act and
will help the NRC maintain a talented
qualified workforce. Lastly, the
Department of Energy Nuclear
Transparency Act ensures transparency
from the DOE as it authorizes nuclear
facilities and its nuclear program. I
want to thank our colleagues from across
the aisle for providing meaningful input
and supporting this important work. I
look forward to reporting these
bipartisan bills favorably out of the
committee and I want to thank every for
their support and also to thank our
great staff for their great work. Thank
you, Mr. Chairman. I yield back.
>> Thank you. The gentleman yields back.
Are there further opening statements?
The gentle lady from Florida recognized
for three minutes for an opening
statement.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman and colleagues.
Uh good morning. I'm pleased today that
we're marking up six um bill by partisan
bills from the energy subcommittee uh
especially to advance American
leadership in nuclear energy. the uh
this continues the committee's work to
carefully balance safety, transparency,
and efficiency and building off the
investments that we've made in the past
through the bipartisan infrastructure
law and the advance act. Thank you, Rep.
Dette and former uh Rep. Jeff Duncan for
that. And while uh nuclear energy can
help address rising electricity demand
in the future, it really doesn't do much
to help our neighbors back home right
now with their immediate challenges, the
soul crushing high electric bills. And
Mr. Chairman, that's why I have to voice
at the beginning of this hearing the
great frustration of that House
Republicans failed to bring the rateayer
protection act to the floor this week.
that could have been something tangible
to help our neighbors back home.
Remember, it passed unanimously out of
this committee in June
uh over a month ago and it was reported
last week that Speaker Johnson and
Majority Leader Scaliz may not bring the
bill to the floor at all in September.
Uh remember the rateayer protection act
will help ensure that data centers pay
their full cost of their energy demand.
Uh, it will make sure that hardworking
families aren't left footing the bill.
It would help states require data
centers to cover the full cost of any
grid upgrades. It would empower local
communities to make decisions on
sighting. It would allow for robust
community input.
These are all policies that I thought we
agreed on. uh but slow walking or or
burying the bill tells a different
story. So I urge you, Mr. Chairman,
maybe you can address it at the end of
my remarks. I I urge you and the
Republicans to bring the Ray Payer
Protection Act to the floor as soon as
possible. And Mr. Mr. Chairman, to to
lower electric bills, this committee
also needs to be working on reforms on
how we plan, permit, and pay for
transmission that can unlock the
electricity our country needs. We have
bills like my expediting generator
interconnection procedures act, which
this committee should advance to fix fix
our system and quickly bring all types
of energy resources to the grid. And
there's still lowhanging fruit as well
to improve grid utilization and deploy
advanced solutions like virtual power
plants to quickly get more energy out of
the grid that we already have. Today's
bills are an important step forward, but
they're not enough. So, let's commit to
do more to work in a bipartisan way to
build the 21st century power system and
lower costs for our neighbors back home.
That's what they're asking for. Thank
you, and I yield back.
>> Thank you. The gentle lady yields back.
Is there any further opening statements
on the Republican side? See none. Any on
the Democrat side? Gentleman from uh New
York is recognized for three minutes for
an opening statement.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman, and good
morning. Today, the committee will
consider four bills that were recently
advanced by the environment
subcommittee. Very happy to see the
emerging bipartisan consensus, that
being that the recycling of critical
minerals already in commerce can be an
important strategy to meet our growing
critical mineral needs. With the right
incentives and regulatory requirements,
lithium ion batteries can be a rich
source of domestic minerals, and we can
ensure their proper collection, reuse,
recycling, and when necessary, disposal
while addressing safety, public health,
and environmental concerns. HR 9615, the
Brace Act, is a good first step. The
bill would allow facilities to store
these batteries prior to recycling them
in accordance with universal waste
requirements while directing EPA to
issue a rule to support the safe
management of lithium ion batteries as
universal waste for the long term. I do
understand this bill is not going to
solve all of our issues with critical
mineral recycling or end of life
handling of batteries. Ultimately, I
believe that a national extended
producer responsibility framework can
play an important role in supporting the
collection, the reuse, and the recycling
of these batteries. And I would be open
to continuing to explore these types of
next step policies as we head into the
120th Congress. Today, we will also
consider HR 2140, the bipartisan
reauthorization of the diesel emissions
reduction act. DRA is an incredibly
effective program that supports the
replacement and retrofit of some of the
worst polluting diesel engines currently
in use. I am glad we can build upon the
success of this program and I look
forward to supporting this bill.
Unfortunately, I must oppose the other
two bills addressing mobile source
pollution. HR 3194, the Locomotives Act,
and HR 9317, the Buses Act, would
curtail state and local government's
ability to adopt common sense
regulations to protect the public from
dangerous air pollution. The Buses Act
seeks to limit state and local
governments from implementing
anti-dolling bus laws, while the
Locomotives Act would prohibit states
from regulating emissions from trains.
State and local governments are on the
front lines of protecting Americans from
air pollution, and I cannot support
efforts to limit their ability to do so,
especially given the Trump EPA's
approach, or lack thereof, to developing
and enforcing meaningful public health
protections. Millions of Americans
continue to suffer from the unsafe
levels of air pollutions. And in the
absence of a strong federal commitment
to environmental protection, I believe
Congress must do everything possible to
encourage our state and local partners
to develop what are sensible public
health protections. With that, I thank
you, Mr. Chair, and yield back.
>> Gentlemen yields back. Are there further
opening statements on the Republican
side? Seeing none on the Democrat side.
Seeing none,
the chair calls up HR 2140 and asks the
clerk to report
HR240,
a bill to amend the energy policy act of
2005 to reauthorize the diesel emissions
reduction program. Section
>> without objection, the first reading of
the bill is dispensed with and the bill
will be open for amendment at any point.
So ordered. Does anyone seek to be
recognized on the bill?
Mr. Chairman,
>> gentlemen from gentle lady from
California is recognized for five
minutes to speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I move to
strike the last word and speak in
support of my bill, the Diesel emissions
reduction act of 2025.
I want to thank Congressman Langworthy
as well as Chairman Guthrie and Chairman
Palmer for working with my office to
move this important legislation through
committee. The Diesel emissions
reduction act or DRA has always been
strongly bipartisan. The DRA program was
created in 2005 by 11 Democrats and 11
Republicans to help reduce pollution
from diesel trucks and improve public
health in communities affected by diesel
pollution. Since 2005, DAR has
repeatedly been reauthorized on a
bipartisan basis and has been
consistently funded every year
regardless of what party controls
Congress. And there's a reason DRA has
been so bipartisan because it's
voluntary. It's cost-effective and it
works. This bill would continue that
successful track record by reauthorizing
and extending the DER program for
another five years. Anyone who's worked
or lived around old diesel engines knows
how dirty those older trucks and buses
can be. The DAR program helps
communities clear up their air by
replacing the oldest and dirtiest
vehicles in their fleets.
Please, states, local governments,
tribes, and school districts can use
this money to replace old trucks, school
buses, construction equipment, and even
even boat engines with newer, cleaner
versions. The new vehicles can be
electric or they can be low emission
propane or national gas vehicles. DRA
gives states and communities flexibility
to decide what technologies are best for
reducing diesel pollution in California.
This program has replaced hundreds of
polluting trucks, tractors, and school
buses. That has a real impact on our
communities. Diesel pollution causes
lung disease, cancer, and heart disease.
And it disproportionately impacts
lowincome communities and children,
which is why it's so important to
replace older diesel school buses. Dior
is a proven common sense solution that
has improved air quality and public
health across California. This is
important bipartisan legislation and
look forward to seeing it signed into
law. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I yel
back.
>> Gentle lady yields back. Is there
further discussion on the bill?
Seeing none.
No further discussion on the bill.
>> No one.
>> Mr. Carter.
>> Oh, Mr. Carter from Louisiana, you're
recognized for five minutes to speak on
the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I'm proud to
support
HR 2140, the diesel emissions reduction
act of 2025. I represent Louisiana,
where some communities are breathing
some of the nation's most polluted air.
Parts of our state already bears a
disproportionate burden of industrial
emissions. Aging trucks, cars, and other
inefficient engine engines pump
additional pollution into the air our
children breathe. Diesel engines can
operate for 30 years or more, leaving
millions of older, dirtier engines in
use. My district is also home of some of
the largest ports in America. While
we're grateful for the vital commerce
and jobs these facilities provide, the
trains, trucks, ships, and industrial
equipment that moves that cargo daily
also increase air pollution for workers
in nearby communities. That's why this
bill which authorizes the diesel
emissions reduction act or dera grant
program through 2029 is so important.
This program is pro is proven common
sense solution that improves air
quality, protects public health, cuts
fuel expenses and supports American
jobs. DRA has delivered real results for
southeast Louisiana, the Port of New
Orleans, and has used this grant funding
to replace dozens of aging trucks with
newer, cleaner trucks equipped with
diesel particulate filters. It's not
just a win for our ports. These awards
also cut diesel pollution in the
surrounding communities. Reauthorizing
Dura through 2029 keeps this
cost-effective healthprotective funding
stream alive for industry and
communities across Louisiana and across
our country. I want to thank
Representative Matsui and Longworthy for
their leadership on this issue and I
urge favorable passage and I yield.
Gentleman yells back. Is there further
discussion on the bill?
Seeing no further discussion, the
question now occurs on adopting HR 2140.
A roll call has been requested and the
clerk will call the role.
>> Mr. Lada.
>> Mr. Lada votes I. Mr. Griffith. Mr.
Griffith votes I. Mr. Bill Rockus. Mr.
Billacus votes I. Mr. Hudson.
Mr. Carter of Georgia. Mr. Carter of
Georgia votes I. Mr. Palmer,
Mr. Dunn,
Mr. Krenshaw,
Mr. Joyce, Mr. Joyce votes I. Mr. Weber,
Mr. Allen,
Mr. Allen votes I. Mr. Balderson,
Mr. Balderson votes I. Mr. Fulture, Mr.
Fulture votes I. Mr. Fluger.
Mrs. Harshburgger. Mrs. Harshburgger
votes I. Mrs. Mrs. Miller Meeks Mrs.
Miller Meeks votes I. Mrs. Kamik
Mr. Obernolulti
Mr. James
Mr. Bence Mr. Bence votes I. Mrs.
Halchin
Mr. Fry Mr. Fry votes I. Ms. Lee
Mr. Langworthy.
Mr. Kain Mr. Kane votes I. Mr. Ruly Mr.
Roelly votes I. Mr. Evans.
>> Mr. Evans votes I. Mr. Goldman. Mr.
Goldman votes I. Mrs. Fedorch. Mrs.
Fedorch votes I. Mr. Palone.
>> Mr. Palone votes I. Miss Dette.
>> Miss Dette votes I. Miss Shakowski.
>> I.
>> Miss Shicowski votes I. Miss Matsui.
>> Miss Matsui votes I. Miss Caster. Miss
Caster votes I. Mr. Tonko.
>> I.
>> Mr. Mr. Tonka votes I. Miss Clark. Ms.
Clark votes I. Mr. Ruiz.
Mr. Peters. Mr. Peters votes I. Mrs.
Dingle. Mrs. Dingle votes I. Mr. Vzy.
Ms. Kelly. Miss. Kelly votes I. Miss.
Baragon. Miss. Baragon votes I. Mr.
Sodto. Mr. Sodto votes I. Miss Shrier.
Miss Shrier votes I. Miss. Trean. Miss
Trean votes I. Miss Fletcher Miss
Fletcher votes I. Miss Aassiocortez
Mr. Aenclaus
Mr. Ashenclaus votes I. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana.
>> Mr. Carter of Louisiana votes I. Mr.
Mendez.
Mr. Mullen. Mr. Mullen votes I. Mr.
Lansman. Mr. Lansman votes I. Miss.
Mlen. Miss. Mlen votes I. Mr. Guthrie.
Mr. Got three votes. I
>> Is anyone seeking recognition? M Mr.
Langworthy.
>> Mr. Lang.
>> Mr. Fluger. Oh, you got you got
Langworthy.
>> Okay. You got Langworthy. You got his
vote in Fluger.
>> M.
>> Mr. Fluger.
>> Palmer.
>> Mr. Palmer is not recorded.
>> Mr. Palmer votes I.
>> Dr. Ruiz. Dr. Ruiz. Yeah.
>> Dr. Ruiz votes I. Anyone either side?
See none, the clerk will report
>> the vote before you report. How's the
gentle lady from New York recorded?
>> Uh, Miss Aassiocortez is not recorded.
>> Miss Aassio Cortez votes I.
>> The clerk will report.
>> Mr. Chairman, on that vote, there were
43 eyes and zero nos.
>> The bill is adopt. The eyes have it. The
bill is adopted.
The chair calls up HR 3194 and ask the
clerk to report.
HR 3194,
a bill to amend the Clean Air Act to
prohibit state standards relating to the
control of emissions from existing.
>> Without objection, the first reading of
the bill is dispensed with and the bill
will be open for amendment at any point.
So ordered. Does anyone seek recognition
on the bill?
Anyone seek recognition on the bill?
>> This is 3194.
Uh
>> yes. 3194.
I see none.
>> The gentleman from gentleman from
Georgia is recognized for five minutes.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
>> The bill.
>> Mr. Chairman, the rail industry is
already taking a proactive approach to
lowering its emission standards
independent of California mandates. The
industry has invested heavily in
modernizing its fleet of locomotives and
significantly increased
the number of locomotives in service
that meet EPA strictest environmental
standards. Rail is one of the cleanest
transportation technologies. US freight
railroads can move one ton of freight
more than 470 miles per gallon of fuel,
making rail the most environmentally
friendly way to move freight over land.
Despite the large volume of freight
move, freight railroads only account for
about6% of total US greenhouse gas
emissions and just 2% of emissions from
transportation related sources.
Unreasonably strict regulations like
those proposed by California would not
incentivize modernization, but would put
companies out of business. Heightening
financial compliance cost across diff
across different states would place
these smaller businesses at substantial
risk and significantly increase the
price of transporting goods. Costs that
would be passed down to the American
consumer. The EPA has already
implemented federal exhaust emission
standards for locomotives with a tiered
system of regulations based on the year
the locomotive was built. The proposed
California requirement advocates for
locomotives older than 23 years to be
reired and replaced by the year 2030
with zero emission locomotives. This
would mean roughly twothirds of all
class one locomotives must be retired
and replaced with zero emission
locomotives. Zero emission locomotives
are still in rollout phases and have not
reached established practice among the
industry.
Mr. Mr. Speaker, I urge my colleagues to
support this bill and I yield the
balance of my time.
>> The gentleman yields. Is there further
discussion on the bill?
>> See, seeing none, no further discussion.
>> Oh, the gentleman from Texas are
recognized for five minutes to speak on
the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. One state's
regulator shouldn't set the rules for
the entire national freight rail
network. That's the problem with the
locomotives acts fixes. In 2023, the
California Air Resources Board proposed
a rule banning any locomotive 23 years
or older from operating in a state
unless it ran zero emissions. The
regulation would have blocked twothirds
of the national locomotive fleet from
reaching two of the nation's largest
ports, forcing trains to stop at the
California border and wait for the
compliant power to finish the job.
That's extra costs and delays passed on
to American consumers. Shortline
railroads would have been hit hardest.
They run on used locomotive passed down
from the class ones because that's what
they can afford. A typical short line
with eight locomotives would have faced
over $2 million a year in compliance
costs against roughly 8 million in
revenue. New new locomotives run three
to4 million a piece. The car's own
assessment admitted that some of their
these businesses would have been
eliminated. And when short lines
disappear, the freight moves to trucks.
Rail moves 40% of long-distance freight
on under 2% of the transportation
emissions. California alone could have
seen over a million additional truck
trips on its highways. Worse for safety,
worse for congestion, worse for the
environment. Carb claims to be
protecting. The Locomotives Act simply
confirms what should already be obvious.
Interstate rail is a national
responsibility, not a California
bureaucrat's job to regulate by waiver.
I'm proud to lead this legislation
alongside Representative Mal Molinar and
Representative Obernoti and I urge my
colleagues to support this legislation
and I'd yield back. Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
>> Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion on the bill?
Gentleman from Colorado is recognized
for five minutes to speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, chairman, and I'm proud to
speak in support of the locomotives act
today. Being led by my colleagues
Molinar, Obernalti, and Goldman, I
represent the heart of Colorado's rail
economy with hundreds of miles of track
running through my district and
thousands of jobs relying on the
industry. This bill helps to protect
those jobs by closing a Clean Air Act
loophole that allows radical states like
California and Colorado to require
trains that pass through their states to
abide by stricter environmental
standards than those set by the federal
government. Like their counterparts in
Sacramento, uh Denver Democrats have
long used the Clean Air Act as cover to
regulate industries they don't like.
This is part of the reason we have a 40%
commercial vacancy rate in downtown
Denver. From targeting America's vital
oil and gas industry to restricting the
use of lawn equipment to mandating the
sale of more expensive gasoline, these
antics drive up the cost of living for
my constituents and hurt jobs. If
California's 2023 waiver request had
been approved, it would have effectively
shut off two of the largest ports in
America from being serviced by 60% of
our nation's rail fleet, inflating the
price of basic goods and hurting the
wallets of working Colorado and American
families. Thankfully, this waiver never
went into effect, but it's more
important than ever to ensure that this
loophole cannot be exploited in the
future. This is why this committee's
work in modernizing the Clean Air Act is
so important. The Locomotives Act and
other bills before us today are simply
common sense. All they do is ensure that
federal environmental law cannot be
weaponized to advance nonsensical
policies that kill jobs and raise the
cost of living. And I'll reiterate a
point that I've made frequently when we
talk about this issue. I am a father who
has a kid who struggles with asthma. No
one wants cleaner air than I do. I want
a healthy environment for all
Coloradoatans and for all Americans. And
that's why we have to follow the science
in this issue. As my colleague just
talked about, if we don't transport it
with rail, it's going to be transported
in ways that have a higher carbon and
emission footprint. Also, if we regulate
our economy to death, we will raise the
cost of living and kill jobs. And
poverty also leads to worse health
outcomes for Americans. This bill
continues building on the intent and
broader goal of many of the other Clean
Air Act uh reforms which have passed the
House earlier this year to include my
bipartisan fire act. It protects jobs
and so I urge my colleagues to join me
in supporting this bill supporting the
environment and I yield back my time.
>> There further discussion on the
underlying bill. I know we have some
amendments but gentle lady from Colorado
is recognized.
>> Thank you Mr. Chairman. Well, you know,
I hadn't planned to speak on this bill,
but I do represent Denver, Colorado, and
I resent the remarks made from my
colleague to the north because for one
thing, they're not rooted in fact. And
if if you want to represent a district,
represent your district, and that's
fine. but attacking quote Denver
Democrats because of the vacancy in
office buildings in downtown Denver and
somehow tying that to the enforcement of
the Clean Air Act is just beyond belief.
I guess it really is campaign season
right now. But for heaven's sakes, I
just want to correct the record. Before
the passage of the 1970 Clean Air Act,
Denver suffered from severe air
pollution exceeding federal air quality
standards for roughly exceeding federal
air quality standards for roughly 200
days per year. I grew up in Denver,
Colorado, and I remember all winter long
you could never see the mountains. After
the Clean Air Act, after we cleaned up
the air, you could see the mountains
every day, you could the kids the the
the percentage of asthma in children
dropped dramatically as my colleague
from the north would be interested to
know since he apparently has a child
with asthma and everybody's health
improved. So, so actually clean air,
clean environment not only improves
people's health, but it also improves
the economy because families can live
there and know that they're going to be
healthy. And that's why the Clean Air
Act has been one of the most successful
environmental
uh uh laws that we've had in this
country. And that's why we need to
continue robust enforcement. I yield
back.
>> Gentle lady yields back. Is there
further discussion?
You have amendments or you want to
discuss the bill underlying bill? Gentle
lady from California is recognized for
five minutes. Oh, I just want to chime
in on this conversation as well because
my my colleague um my Republican
colleague from Colorado is all of a
sudden concerned about the high cost for
American families when my colleague has
done nothing but vote for policies that
have raised cost for American families,
including those in Colorado.
Um what's really costing I is uh these
policies for a war that's costing $73
billion which is making prices go up.
It's the cost of groceries and housing
and everything else which my colleague
has done nothing about. So to hear him
talk about the cost on families and the
concern is kind of falling on deaf ears.
The other thing is that these local
motives that are old and inefficient
they are relying on diesel. Well, guess
what's going up? Diesel. The cost of
diesel. The reliance on diesel has
become a lot more expensive. Why? Due to
Trump's war on Iran. Something my
colleague in Colorado
won't speak up against and won't say,
"Hey, this is costing more dollars."
Instead, just putting a stamp on
anything this administration does, which
is making costs go up for American
families. With that, I yield back.
Gentle lady yields back. Seeing no
further discussion, are there
amendments? Gentleman from Texas is
recognized. For what purpose? Gentleman
from Texas seek recognition.
>> Uh Mr. Chairman, I have an amendment at
the desk.
>> The clerk will report the amendment.
>> Amendment to HR 3194
offered by Mr.
>> Without objection, the reading the
amendment is dispensed with and the
gentleman from Texas is recognized for
five minutes in support of the
amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. This is a
conforming amendment that updates the
locomotives act to reflect the new subp
paragraph added in our introduced bill.
This change ensures the bill functions
as intended and that the bill is aligned
with the provisions it amends in the
clean air act and I yield back.
>> Jim yields back. Is there further
discussion? This is a conforming
amendment.
So see no discussion on the amendment.
All those in favor shall signify by
saying I.
>> I. All oppose? Nay. The eyes have it and
the amendment is agreed to.
>> Are there further amendments? Any
further amendments?
>> You have an amendment.
>> Oh, from California. What purpose you
seek recognition?
>> Mr. Chair, I have an amendment at the
desk. HR 3194_03.
>> The clerk will report.
>> Amendment to HR 3194. Without objection,
the amendment reading of the amendment
is dispensed with and the gentle lady
from California is recognized for five
minutes in support of the amendment.
>> Uh thank you, Mr. Chair. Um my amendment
ensures that states can shield their
communities from the serious public
health costs of local motive emissions.
Local motives are a major source of
harmful emissions that pose a serious
public health risk. This is especially
true for the railard workers and
communities living near rail yards,
which are predominantly low-income
communities and communities of color. I
represent a district that stands to be
the most affected. It's the ports of Los
Angeles and Long Beach use diesel
freight rail to transport goods to and
from the ports. Diesel emissions affect
rail workers and nearby communities.
California workers in rail yards have
reported health issues they see from
these emissions at work and at home with
reports of headaches and shortness of
breath on the job and high rates of
asthma among their kids and their
grandkids. A Southern California
pediatrician has highlighted the direct
connection between rail admissions and
public health. He said, and I'm quoting,
"Lean up real yard pollution will help
keep these kids in their classrooms and
playing with their friends, not in my
exam rooms." End quote. This is a
problem in communities near rail yards
across the country. In Kansas, families
living near major rail operations have
raised the same concerns. One Kansas
City child care provider said, and I
quote, "We saw a lot of asthma and
respiratory problems in the children we
take care of." End quote. When we ignore
the serious costs of local motive
emissions, it is our communities that
bear the consequences, doctor visits,
hospital trips, treatment for asthma,
and respiratory illnesses. These costs
add up and families are the ones paying
the price. The polluted air they are
forced to breathe harms their health and
eats away at their finances. We should
not stand by and watch our community
suffer.
We should give states the tools that
they need to protect their communities,
not tie their hands. So, I call on my
colleagues to support this amendment
which prevents the Local Motives Act
from blocking a state pollution standard
for locomotives if the EPA administrator
finds that the standard will prevent
premature deaths and save on healthcare
cost. With that, I yield back.
>> Gentle lady yields back. Is there
further discussion on the amendment?
Gentleman from Pennsylvania is
recognized for five minutes to speak on
the amendment.
>> I seek to be recognized to speak in
opposition to this amendment. This is a
measured and reasonable bill that allows
for up to 15 minutes of idling that is
necessary to perform required safety
checks and to make sure that the
passengers are loaded safely and have
access to air conditioning and other
features. Buses are already an efficient
and an affordable form of
transportation. The real threat to cost
and affordability are the risks of
substantial enforcement fines and
litigation by bounty hunters. This
legislation will reduce burden and costs
for many small companies and for those
who already rely on this form of
affordable, safe and reliable
transportation. We should be encouraging
more buses, not making it more difficult
for them to operate. I urge a no vote on
this amendment and I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back. The gentleman
from New Jersey is recognized for five
minutes to speak on the amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I want to speak
in support of the gentleoman from
California's amendment. The
transportation sector is a leading
source of health harming air pollution
and America's diesel-powered locomotives
remain a major and often overlooked
contributor. Locomotives emit nitrogen
oxides and diesel particulate matter
leading to devastating health
consequences for those living and
working in communities near rail yards,
ports, and transit centers. And I know
the gentleoman is from California, but I
will tell you that the same is true. Uh
the same concerns for our ports uh in
New Jersey. It's estimated that the rail
industry is responsible for up to 3,100
premature deaths annually with total
health related costs of up to $48
billion. at HR 3914 attacks state's
ability to adopt or enforce emission
standards for inuse locomotives,
allowing older and dirtier locomotive
engines to continue to pollute and
poison communities for decades. This is
a common sense amendment. It seeks to
protect standards for inuse locomotives
that will result in avoided premature
deaths and savings on health care costs.
Policies that help prevent dire health
consequences and save Americans money in
the process are the ones we should be
able to support. We should be fighting
to raise the standard of living for
those living and working near major
transit centers, not lowering it. So, I
urge my colleagues to support this
common sense amendment and I yield back,
Mr. Chairman.
>> Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion of the amendment?
>> Seeing none, if there's no further
discussion, the verd occurs on the
amendment.
>> We have one.
>> Oh, you Oh, Mr. Tucker. Okay. Gentleman
from New York recognized for five
minutes.
>> Thank you, Mr. Speaker. I move to strike
the last word.
>> Gentleman's recognized and speak on the
amendment.
>> Thank you. Um I express my support for
the Barana amendment which would exclude
emission standards that would result in
avoided premature deaths and savings on
health care costs from the bill's
preeemption of state authorities.
Locomotives are a significant source of
harmful air pollution, including
particulate matter and nitrogen oxide.
And while EPA has issued several
standards known as TEIRS for nearly
manufactured for newly manufactured
engines, old locomotives remain in use
today and they are greatly contributing
to many areas pollution problems. As of
2020 in California, more than 1/ half of
locomotives in service were tier 1 or
earlier. And the standard for these
locomotives allow nearly 10 times as
much pollution compared to new tier 4
equipment. These locomotives can and
likely will continue to be used for
decades to come. And it becomes a real
challenge for state governments to work
around these sources of emissions to
achieve their pollution reduction goals
and better protect public health.
Exposure to locomotive emissions can
lead to cancer and increases in asthma,
cardoppulmonary illness,
hospitalizations, and premature deaths.
And these emissions are most likely to
occur in neighborhoods that already
experience disproportionately high
levels of air pollution near rail yards
and ports with significant rail
activity. If any state were to be
serious about pursuing a standard for
inuse locomotives, I'm certain it would
not be done lightly and it would not be
done to punitively impose costs on rail
carriers. It would be seen as an
important part of reducing pollution and
protecting the public. Given that our
federal emissions regulator, the EPA, is
asleep at the wheel when it comes to
protecting public health from dangerous
air pollution, we should not prevent
states from stepping up to fill this
gap. So, I urge members to support this
amendment and Mr. Chair, I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back and the gentleman
from Alabama is recognized for five
minutes to speak on the amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I rise in
opposition to the amendment.
Um, HR 3194 does not alter the ability
of states like California to regulate
internal emission sources. States would
still be able to seek EPA waiverss for
internal emission sources like intercity
rail, automobiles, and heavy machinery.
Instead, it protects other states
dependent on the National Rail System
from overreaching mandates from states
like California by ensuring that federal
preeemption over interstate commerce is
protected. Such overreaches have been
credibly forecasted to dramatic
dramatically raise cost for shippers and
consumers by burdening states with
mandates their constituencies did not
vote for. Regulations like those
proposed by California are infeasible
and unrealistic in ways that would have
harmful cascading consequences on states
across the country. HR 3194 continues to
push states toward long-term air quality
goals through federal regulation of
interstate commerce by closing a
loophole that undermines those goals.
Railways cover 40% of long-distance
freight with less than 2% of the
emissions. Restricting locomotives,
locomotives through patchwork
regulations not only increases consumer
cost and and threatens our supply chain,
but also would increase air emissions.
California should not be allowed to set
national policy restricting interstate
commerce. This legislation prevents
states like California from implementing
heightened standards and compliance
costs at the detriment of all states. I
urge a no vote on this amendment and I
yield back.
>> The gentleman yields back. Is there
further discussion on the amendment?
Seeing none,
>> you want to Okay. The question now
recurs on the amendment. A roll call has
been requested and the clerk will call
the role.
>> Mr. Lada.
>> Mr. votes no. Mr. Griffith,
>> Mr. Griffith votes no. Mr. Bilarus,
>> Mr. Bilarus votes no. Mr. Hudson,
Mr. Carter of Georgia,
>> Mr. Carter of Georgia votes no. Mr.
Palmer,
>> Mr. Palmer votes no. Mr. Dunn.
Mr. Krenshaw.
Mr. Joyce.
>> Mr. Joyce votes no. Mr. Weber.
>> Mr. Weber votes no. Mr. Allen.
>> Mr. Allen votes no. Mr. Balderson
>> Mr. Balderson votes no. Mr. Fulture Mr.
Fulture votes no. Mr. Fluger
>> Mr. Fluger votes no. Mrs. Harshburgger
>> Mrs. Harshburgger votes no. Mrs. Miller
Mrs. Miller Meeks votes no. Mrs. Kamik
Mrs. Kamik votes no. Mr. Obernulty.
Mr. James.
Mr. Bence. Mr. Mr. B votes no. Mrs.
Houchin Mrs. Houchin votes no. Mr. Fry.
Ms. Lee. Miss Lee votes no. Mr.
Langworthy.
>> Mr. Langworthy votes no. Mr. Kain Mr.
Kane votes no. Mr. Roelly. Mr. Roelly
votes no. Mr. Evans. Mr. Evans votes no.
Mr. Goldman. Mr. Goldman votes no. Mrs.
Fedorch.
Mrs. Fedorch votes no. Mr. Mr. Palone.
>> Mr. Palone votes I. Miss Dette.
>> Miss Dette votes I. Miss Shakowski.
>> I.
>> Miss Shakowski votes I. Miss Matsui.
>> Miss Matsuie votes I. Miss Caster.
>> Miss Caster votes I. Mr. Tonko.
>> I.
>> Mr. Tonko votes I. Miss. Clark. Miss.
Clark votes I. Mr. Ruiz. Mr. Ruiz votes
I. Mr. Peters. Mr. Peters votes I. Mrs.
Dingle. Mrs. Dingle votes I. Mr. Vzy.
Miss. Kelly.
Miss. Kelly votes I. Miss. Beran. Miss.
Beran. Votes. I. Mr. Sodto. Mr. Sodto
votes I. Miss. Shrier. Miss Shrier votes
I. Miss. Tran. Miss. Tran votes I. Miss.
Fletcher.
Miss Aassio Cortez. Miss Aassiocortez
votes I. Mr. Aenclaus
Mr. Aenclaus votes I. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana. Mr. Carter of Louisiana votes
I. Mr. Mendez.
Mr. Mullen. Mr. Mullen votes I. Mr.
Lansman. Mr. Lansman votes I. Mrs. Ms.
Mlen. Ms. Mlen votes I. Mr. Guthrie. Mr.
Guthrie votes no.
M. Mr. Mr. Hudson votes no.
>> Mr. Fry votes no.
>> Miss Fletcher votes I.
>> Seeing no others uh for right requesting
to vote, the clerk will report the
result.
Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 22
eyes's and 26 nos.
>> The amendment is not agreed to. Are
there further amendments?
Are there further amendments?
No.
If there are no further amendments, the
question now occurs on adopting HR 3194.
A roll call has been requested and the
clerk will call the role.
>> Mr. Lada,
>> Mr. Lada votes I.
>> Mr. Griffith,
>> let me make a correction. We did have a
conforming amendment pass. So I will
call it. The question now occurs on
adopting HR 3194 as amended. A roll call
has been requested. The clerk will call
the role.
>> Mr. Lada. Mr. Mr. Lada votes I. Mr.
Griffith Mr. Griffith votes I. Mr. Bill
Rockus.
Mr. Bill Rockus votes I. Mr. Hudson.
Mr. Carter of Georgia.
>> Mr. Carter of Georgia votes I. Mr.
Palmer.
Mr. Palmer votes I. Mr. Dunn.
Mr. Krenshaw.
Mr. Joyce. Mr. Joyce votes I. Mr. Weber
Mr. Weber votes I. Mr. Allen Mr. Allen
votes I. Mr. Balderson Mr. Balderson
votes I. Mr. Fulture Mr. Fulture votes
I. Mr. Fluger. Mr. Fluger votes I. Mrs.
Harshburgger. Mrs. Harshburgger votes I.
Mrs. Miller Meeks. Mrs. Kamik.
Mrs. Kamik votes I. Mr. Obernolulty.
Mr. James
Mr. Bence Mr. Bence votes I. Mrs.
Houchin Mrs. Howchin votes I. Mr. Fry
Mr. Fry votes I. Miss Lee Miss Lee votes
I. Mr. Langworthy. Mr. Langworthy votes
I. Mr. Kaine. Mr. Kain votes I. Mr.
Roelly. Mr. Roelly votes I. Mr. Evans.
Mr. Evans votes I. Mr. Goldwin. Mr.
Goldman votes I. Mrs. Mrs. Fedorch Mrs.
Fedorek votes I. Mr. Palone Mr. Palone
votes no. Miss Dette Miss Dette votes
no. Miss Shakowski.
>> Miss Shakowski votes no. Miss Mattsuie.
>> Miss Matsui votes no. Miss Caster.
>> Miss Caster votes no. Mr. Tonko
>> no.
>> Mr. Tonko votes no. Miss Clark. Miss
Clark votes no. Mr. Ruiz. Mr. Ruiz votes
no. Mr. Peters. Mr. Peters votes no.
Mrs. Dingle. Mrs. Dingle votes no. Mr.
Vzy.
Ms. Kelly. Miss Kelly votes no. Miss
Baragon. Miss Baragon votes no. Mr.
Sodto. Mr. Sodto votes no. Miss Shrier.
Miss Shrier votes no. Miss Trean. Miss.
Trean votes no. Miss. Fletcher. Miss.
Fletcher votes no. Miss Aassio Cortez.
Miss Aassio Cortez votes no. Mr.
Aenclaus Mr. Aenclaus votes no. Mr.
Carter of Louisiana. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana votes no. Mr. Mendez.
Mr. Mullen. Mr. Mullen votes no. Mr.
Lansman. Mr. Lansman votes no. Miss.
Mlen.
Miss. Mlen votes no. Mr. Guthrie.
>> Mr. Guthrie votes I.
Mr. Hudson votes I.
Miss Miller Mrs. Miller Meeks votes I.
>> Mr. Vzy is not recorded.
Mr. Vzy votes no.
>> Seeing no others here to seek to enter
the roll call. The clerk will report.
Uh, she voted.
>> Yes.
>> How's Miss Dingle record? I think she
voted.
>> Mrs. Dingle is recorded as a no.
>> Yes.
>> Clerk will report.
>> Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 26
eyes and 23 nos.
>> The eyes have it and the bill is
adopted.
The chair calls up HR 9317 and asks the
clerk to report
>> HR 9317,
a bill to prohibit engine idling
restrictions for over the road buses.
>> Without objection, the first reading of
the bill is dispensed with and the bill
will be open for amendment at any point.
So order. Does anyone seek to be
recognized on the bill?
>> Gentleman from New York. What purp you
seek recognition?
You're recognized for five minutes to
speak on the bill.
>> My bill HR 9317, the buses utilizing
safety and environmental standards act
or the buses act comes down to one
simple principle. Passenger safety
should come before an arbitrary
stopwatch. Look at what's happening in
New York City. The general idling limit
is three minutes. Next to a school, it
drops to one minute. Now think about
that. Three minutes is to safely prepare
a bus carrying dozens of passengers one
minute outside of a school. Anyone who
has watched a school bus load children
knows how unrealistic uh those numbers
can be. Kids aren't cargo. Drivers may
be helping younger children, waiting for
a student to safely cross the street or
assisting a child with disabilities. And
passenger safety starts before anyone
even boards. Drivers must conduct
pre-trip safety checks, inspect critical
systems, and make sure that the vehicle
is safe before putting passengers on the
road. Three minutes goes by pretty
quickly when you're responsible for an
entire busload of people. And nowhere is
that more obvious than for passengers
with disabilities. For someone using a
wheelchair, boarding a bus isn't as
simple as walking through the door. A
driver may need to deploy a wheelchair
lift, assist the passenger into the
vehicle, properly secure the wheelchair,
check the restraints, and make
absolutely certain that that person is
safe before the bus starts to move. That
can take more than 3 minutes alone, and
it certainly can take more than one
minute. And that's okay.
What are we telling that driver to do
when the clock is running? Rush the
lift, rush the passenger, cut corners,
securing the wheelchair, tell a child
with a disability that they need to
hurry up. Absolutely not. No passenger
with a disability should ever feel that
they're holding up a bus because a
government regulation says that the
driver is taking too long. And no driver
should feel the pressure to rush that
passenger because they're worried about
an idling ticket. But New York City
takes this even further. They allow
private citizens to report idling
violations and then receive a financial
award. So, while a driver is conducting
safety checks or helping a passenger
using a wheelchair safely board, someone
could be standing on the sidewalk with a
phone a phone pointed at that bus
filming it, watching the clock, and
hoping to make money off a potential
violation. Some participants have
reportedly made hundreds of thousands of
dollars in this new cottage industry.
Think about how backward that is. We're
creating a financial incentive to hunt
for idling violations while drivers may
be doing exactly what we expect and need
them to do. Protect their passengers.
The Buses Act restores common sense by
establishing a reasonable 15minute
national standard so that operators have
time to conduct their safety checks
safely board their passengers, operate
accessible equipment, and make sure that
everyone is secure. This isn't about
unnecessary idling. It's about passenger
safety. And when the choice is between
beating an arbitrary clock and taking
another minute to keep passengers safe,
I want the driver choosing safety every
single time. And that's what the buses
act protects. I urge my colleagues to
support the bill and I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back. Gentleman from
New Jersey is recognized for five
minutes to speak on the bill.
>> Uh thank you, Mr. Chairman. I'll speak
in opposition to the bill. As America's
children return to class this September,
many start the day on a school bus. 25
million to be exact. And the vast
majority of those buses are diesel
powered, subjecting children, drivers,
and surrounding communities to health
harming pollution like fine particulate
matter and nitrogen oxides. Children are
particularly susceptible to the health
impacts of diesel exhaust, and early
exposure can lead to long-term health
challenges, interfere with lung growth,
and impact children's cognitive
development. At HR 9317, the buses act
would allow school buses to
unnecessarily idle for 15 minutes or
more. Most state and local idling
restrictions are limited to roughly 3 to
5 minutes, even less around schools, and
already include a range of exemptions
for things like safety and extreme
temperatures. But the buses act would
triple some state idling restrictions,
marking an extreme departure from these
common sense protections. While
September marks back to school season
for children across the country, it also
marks the six-month anniversary of
Trump's disastrous war in Iran that is
causing fuel costs to spike across the
country. Americans have already spent
$95 billion more on gasoline and diesel
fuel since the start of Trump's war in
Iran. At the end of the last school
year, schools were reporting strained
budgets thanks to high diesel costs.
Wasting expensive fuel through excessive
engine idling like what the buses act
promotes would exacerbate the current
fuel affordability crisis. The buses act
is not a safety solution. It sets a weak
national standard for engine idling
without any guardrails and would leave
communities to foot the bill with their
health and their wallets. Furthermore,
the buses act infringes on states
ability to address the unique air
quality and transportation needs of
their communities and drives up health
harming pollution. So I urge my
colleagues to oppose this bill and I
yield back. Mr. Chairman,
>> gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion on the bill? Is there further
discussion on the bill? Seeing none, are
there any amendments? Gentleman from uh
California is recognized. Uh what
purpose? Gentleman from California seek
recognition.
>> Mr. Chairman, I have an amendment at the
desk.
>> The clerk will report. You identify the
amendment. Do you have the amendment?
The clerk will report.
>> Amendment to HR 9317
offered by Mr. Peters, page two, line
nine, strike minutes and insert minutes.
>> Without objection, the reading amendment
is dispensed with. Make sure it's a it's
the correct amendment, right? That's the
correct is dispensed with and the
gentleman is recognized for five minutes
in support of the amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Uh at the uh
subcommittee hearing, I heard Mr.
Langworthy's um discussion of the
practical problems u posed by the um 3m
minute to five minute idling requirement
and uh indicated at that excuse me
indicated at that time that um while I
was sympathetic to it the bill was drawn
really broadly to not limit itself to
any such exemptions and I said that time
excuse me if you narrowed the exemption
I would have to be um I would be tempted
to vote for this because I I think the u
the issues around disability and about
um inspections were were um reasonable
and persuasive and usually nothing ever
happens when that when I do that but
actually um to the credit of the
majority they've agreed to all the
changes that I've requested
uh and so my amendment would narrowly
tailor the scope of the bill to ensure
that localities give operators one
15minute period of idling exclusively
for pre-trip inspections, the loading of
passengers with disabilities and the
temperature control concurrent with a
pre-trip inspection. If an operator is
idling for other reasons outside of
those three, they can and should be
still held to violation of local rules,
could be held accountable. Uh the
amendment would preserve state and local
uh enforcement programs and make it
clear that if an operator is idling for
purposes outside of pre-trip
inspections, the loading of passengers
with disabilities, or temperature
control concurrent with pre-trip
inspections, that is still a violation.
So instead of directing states or
localities to terminate their program,
the amendment would give them the
flexibility to amend their program to
comply with this bill. Um I think this
is how it's supposed to work. I credit
um the the chairman um Guthrie and and
Mr. Gutheimr, Mr. Langworthy for working
with me to to make this amendment. And
to my colleagues on this side of the
aisle, I would say this, the Republicans
are going to pass this bill. Um my
amendment narrows it. Uh makes it much
more acceptable to us. And even if you
disagree with the um the final bill for
some of the reasons that Mr. Palone
states, um I think that I would
appreciate your help in narrowing the
scope of it. U and I, if this um this
amendment does pass, will be willing to
support the bill. And with that, I yield
back.
>> Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion on the amendment? The
gentleman from New Jersey is recognized
for five minutes to speak on the
amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I'm actually
speaking in opposition to the amendment.
And let me say I appreciate that um the
gentleman from California is attempting
to narrow the engine idling restrictions
for certain purposes, but the reality is
that most state engine idling
restrictions already include a range of
exceptions for things like safety,
extreme temperatures, and inspections.
In fact, the very program that this bill
targets in New York City already
includes an idling exception for loading
and unloading passengers. So the reality
is there are other techniques that can
be deployed like engine idle reduction
technologies that help minimize the time
an engine operates, save on fuel, and
help with cabin comfort as well as
equipment operation. But I so I think we
should be encouraging the adoption of
these technologies as opposed to setting
a weak federal for engine idling
restrictions in state implementation
plans. The amendment really does nothing
to address the serious problems with the
buses act. It continues to unnecessarily
subject children to toxic air pollution
and waste expensive diesel fuels. So I
urge my colleagues to oppose this
amendment and I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back and the gentleman
from New York is recognized for five
minutes to speak on the amendment.
>> I uh I want to thank Mr. Peters and his
staff for their work on a bipartisan
compromise. I'd also like to thank Mr.
Godheimer and his staff for working with
my office on this important legislation.
And I'm glad we could reach an agreement
on this common sense reform that allows
buses to perform necessary trip safety
checks and assist passengers. And I urge
my colleagues to vote in favor of this
amendment.
>> Chairman yields back. Further discussion
of the amendment. Gentle lady from
Virginia is recognized for five minutes
to speak on the amendment.
>> Um, thank you, Mr. Chair. Speaking
against the amendment, this amendment
and the underlying bill ignores a very
practical solution
to the issue that the gentleman from New
York raised. if you have a bus driver
that needs to assist uh a student with a
disability or if they need to do an
inspection and that's turn the bus off.
Um because it's a fact that leaving a
diesel bus idling for 15 or 20 minutes
is significantly worse for engine
health, fuel fuel consumption, uh and
emissions than if you just turn the bus
off and restart it when you are finished
15 or 20 minutes later. Um, a heavy duty
diesel bus burns um about 0.5 to a
gallon of fuel for every hour it sits
idling. And when you restart a diesel
engine, it uses only a fraction of the
fuel, about the same amount of fuel that
you would use if you left the bus idling
for 10 seconds. And so keeping the bus
idling extends wear and tear on the
combustion engine because there's
incomplete combustion. When you turn the
engine off, do what you need to do for
15 to 20 minutes and then turn the bus
back on. That is a much more efficient
solution from a fuel consumption, from
an engine wear and tear, and from an
emissions standard. And I just I think
this bill is ignoring a very practical
solution to the problem. The problem
it's trying to solve.
>> Yel back. Okay. Thanks. Gentle lady
yields back. Uh any further discussion
on the amendment? On the amendment.
Seeing none, all in favor shall signify
by saying I. I.
>> Of those opposed, nay.
The eyes have it and amendment is agreed
to. Are there further amendments? Gentle
lady from New York, you're recognized
for what person? Gentle from New York
recognition.
>> I have an amendment at the desk.
>> Identify the amendment.
>> Uh FC AMD HR 931706.
>> Clerk report.
Amendment to HR 9317
offered by
>> without objection the reading the
amendment is dispensed with and the
gentle lady from New York is recognized
for five minutes in support of the
amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Um, you know, I
find it
fascinating sometimes when there's a lot
of discourse here about one-sizefits-all
policies and about how folks in urban
areas shouldn't dictate how people in
more rural areas live, which makes
complete sense, but I don't what I don't
understand is why the opposite doesn't
apply here. Uh the the congressman is
not from New York City. So I'm I
represent
Asthma Alley, the South Bronx,
kids whose lungs have been choked with
smog for decades. And my own nephews, my
own family can't get through a day of
school without a nebulizer.
A 15minute idling restriction is
extraordinarily high in concentrated
city streets.
And what might be okay in a different
area is very much not okay when it comes
to kindergarteners trying to get on
their way to school.
High CO2 outputs
have statistically shown to reduce
cognitive performance by 15 to 50%.
And in fact, when we look at kids
standardized test performance, we're
looking at a 10 to 15% difference with
kids who are trying to learn in areas
with polluted air.
These idling provisions make a massive
difference. And one of the most
important things that I do in my work is
to fight for kids in the South Bronx.
One in five kids in the South Bronx in
these neighborhoods have asthma. And I
want to be very clear that the
provisions in this bill target New York
City and my community specifically and
uniquely. No other municipality in the
United States has a reporting program
like New York Cities. And this provision
is targeting our municipality's ability
to protect our children.
These common sense provisions, all of
these things that are talking about
about how people will be penalized for
helping a kid in a wheelchair is a fairy
tale. That does not happen. There are
already common sense exemptions in the
law for safety, for conditions. We're
not letting people freeze in the debt of
winter and we're not reporting people
who are trying to safely load someone
with a disability. But what we are
trying to do is prevent kids from
developing further disabilities
like asthma, further disabilities and
diseases because this is one of the most
undererved areas in the United States.
And I will not sit here and allow them
to be trampled on and ignored and talked
about in this way. Municipalities and
communities have and should have the
ability to regulate according to the
realities of their local backyard. New
York City is doing that and has the
right to do that just like any other
community in the United States. And so
my amendment that I am proposing today
is that that this act shall not take
effect until the administrator of the
EPA certifies that its implementation
will not increase children's exposure to
air pollution because I will not sit
here and allow my kids to get choked
with smog because people do not
understand the realities of what this
does to their brains. And with that, I
yield back.
>> Gentle lady yields back. Is there
discussion? The gentleman from New York
is recognized for five minutes to speak
on the amendment.
>> Thank you very much, Mr. Chairman. This
amendment is another attempt to prevent
the buses act from taking effect. It
would require the EPA administrator to
certify that this legislation will not
result in any increase in children's
exposure from air pollution before the
bill could be implemented. And of
course, we should care about children's
health. But let's also remember who's
actually riding these buses. Children.
Every morning, millions of parents put
their children on a school bus and trust
that the driver is going to get them to
school safely. And safely operating that
bus takes time. Drivers need to complete
all of the checks and make sure that
vehicle's ready for the road. They need
to safely load those children. And a lot
of children need extra assistance. Uh,
as I spoke of earlier, children with
wheelchairs and lifts, they need extra
time. That takes time. New York City has
an idling limit next to a school that is
one minute. One minute. Do we really
want a school bus driver looking at a
stopwatch while trying to help a
disabled child on on to the bus? Do we
want to rush that wheelchair lift or cut
short that safety check because they're
worried about someone filming their bus
to cash in and and and create income for
themselves on the backs of the bus
driver? Of course not. And the buses act
does not require buses to idle for 15
minutes. And it doesn't encourage
unnecessary idling. It simply provides a
reasonable window when operators need
the time to do their safety checks. And
if they're ready to leave sooner, they
leave sooner. But if a bus needs a few
more minutes to safely board a child, to
complete its necessary safety
procedures, or secure a wheelchair, that
child's safety should come before an
arbitrary one minute timeline that's
been put in place. This amendment would
put the entire law on hold until the EPA
makes an extraordinarily broad
certification while doing nothing to
address the very real safety challenges
that our drivers face today. And if
we're serious about protecting children,
let's protect them when they're
passengers, too. No child should ever be
rushed onto a school bus because an
arbitrary clock is running or someone is
trying to create a for-profit mission to
get penalties assessed to a driver. And
I urge my colleagues to reject this
amendment and I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion on the amendment? Gentle lady
from New York is recognized for five
minutes to speak on the amendment.
>> I thank you, Mr. Chairman. Let me just
say that first of all, it's very clear
to me that the gentleman has no idea of
how um students with disabilities are
administered in the city of New York
that the bus driver is not the only
person attending to these students. They
typically have attendance so that there
is a safety precautions in place with
personnel able to move the students in a
timely manner. With that, I'm going to
yield to uh the gentle lady from New
York, Miss Kaziocortez.
>> Uh I thank the gentle lady once again.
You know, my the the congressman is not
from New York City and is characterizing
a program that he is not familiar with.
We are attempting to communicate that
you are mistaken in your
characterization
of the program.
the the there are exceptions to load
children for safety ex inspections for
these types of operations to load kids
onto school buses. So these scenarios
that you are describing are incorrect,
not factual, do not exist and are not
supported by any evidence. What I find
strange about this conversation is that
when presented with that there is a
continuation to perpetuate something
that is not true. Read the statute
there. There are exceptions for kids.
All of these things that you did that
you are alleging happened do not comport
with city policy. And so a public
mischaracterization
of this law that does not comport with
reality is being used to justify passage
of a law that is going to make kids
sick. For what reason? I simply do not
understand why we are not telling the
truth about this and why we are trying
to advance and target a provision for a
district from which the congressman
respectfully does not represent and
it will hurt children.
I the thing about this is that when you
represent an area like the South Bronx,
you have to fight and scrap for every
tiny thing so that every child can get a
1% chance, a 5% chance at improving at
any small outcome that they have.
This idling provision makes a
difference. We're talking about the
difference of 10 to 15% points on a
standardized test score. That's the
difference between a kid getting a 60 on
a state test and a kid getting an 85.
The number of pollution and smog that
they are being choked with that
surrounds that school. So what I am
requesting is for us to preserve our
freedom to protect our children. If you
want to do this to your kids, that's
your business. But I will not allow this
to be done to mine. And with that, I
yield back.
>> Gentle lady from New York.
>> I yield back.
>> Yields back. I guess you're both from
New York. So, yeah. Gentle. Uh, so
gentle lady from New York has yielded
has yield back. Is there further
discussion on the amendment? Gentle lady
from none of the Republicans and gentle
from Virginia is recognized for five
minutes.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chair. Diesel exhaust has
been designated as a carcinogenic to
humans
by the International Agency for Research
on Cancer.
It contains significant levels of
particulate matter that can lodge deep
into the lungs and heart that are linked
to pre premature death, aggravated
asthma, and decreased young lung
function. And children are particularly
susceptible because their respiratory
systems are still developing and they
breathe faster.
And this bill
ignores and takes away a tool from
states and localities
to deal with the pollution that they
have to better protect children,
including the ones that are riding the
bus. And most schools are in residential
neighborhoods. So, you're also
protecting the children and the people
who live around the school.
While we legislate in silos, these
communities don't live in silos. And so
a lot of urban
cities like the one I represent in
Hopewell, Virginia have very high
concentrations
of industry or chemical plants that are
also putting particulates out into the
air and as a result have some of the
highest incidences of asthma of any
other localities in the state.
And a lot of the schools that these kids
are attending
struggle with mold because there may be
more moisture in the air and a lot of
these schools are over a hundred years
old
and their HVAC systems are breaking.
We're fighting that right now in the
city of Richmond.
And this bill
would take away a tool from our
localities to help protect children from
a carcinogen
when the problems that the gentleman
from New York has identified
can be easily solved by turning off the
bus.
Because an idling bus uses more gas,
diesel fuel,
is harder on the engine, and pumps out
more particulate matter and pollution
than if you turn the bus off and then
you turn it back on. And so rather than
saying we're going to have a
one-sizefits-all
rule that ignores that some localities
are struggling to keep their children
from having asthma attacks more than
others
is is doesn't make sense to me. And then
on top of that, you have
families
who because who are who are losing their
health insurance
either because the enhanced premium tax
credits under the ACA have expired and
they can't afford it
or come January, you'll have a lot of
people who lose access to their
insurance.
And you may wonder, what does that have
to do with asthma? Well, last week I was
at a round table with the president of a
free clinic who told the story of a
family who could no longer afford
the abbruterol and the inhaler for their
child who had asthma.
So, they had to cut back on how much
they bought.
And then
their son had an asthma attack and died
because they could not afford
the inhaler.
This is serious business that can be the
difference for one kid between life and
death if they have an asthma attack. and
saying to whether it's New York City or
Hopewell or California or wherever that
you know better
than the officials there what they need
to do to keep
bus exhaust
from impacting kids
is it just doesn't make sense to me and
that's why I support the representatives
amendment to this misguided bill and I
yield
Gentle lady yields back. Is there
further discussion on the amendment?
Seeing a gentleman from New Jersey is
recognized for five minutes to speak on
the amendment. Thank you, Chairman. I
want to speak in favor of uh Congressman
Okasiocortez's amendment. Um while I
don't represent New York City, I
represent the Ironbound section of
Newark where children that live in the
Ironbound uh about one in four suffer
from asthma because of the environmental
conditions that they live and go to
school under each and every day. And as
people that represent these densely
populated districts, we have to utilize
every tool available to us to get better
health outcomes for everyone that we
represent, but especially our children.
And so I appreciate the congresswoman's
amendment, which would simply prevent
the act from going into effect until the
APA administrator certifies that the act
will not result in an increased
children's exposure to air pollution.
That's something we should all be
aligned on, and I certainly am. uh
whether it's thinking about idling buses
or making sure that we have more
electric buses that are going through
our communities. Those are the fights
that we need to have and we will
continue to fight for everyone that we
represent. And I especially think it's
important to consider the members
perspective who represent the
municipalities uh in question. And so I
I support this amendment and thank her
for her leadership on it. I yield back.
>> Yields back. Is there further discussion
on the amendment?
Seeing no further discussion, the
question occurs on the amendment. A roll
call has been requested and the clerk
will call the role.
>> Mr. Lau,
Mr. Lauder votes no. Mr. Griffith, Mr.
Griffith votes no. Mr. Bill Rockus. Mr.
Bill Rockus votes no. Mr. Hudson,
Mr. Carter of Georgia. Mr. Carter of
Georgia votes no. Mr. Palmer Mr. Palmer
votes no. Mr. Dunn,
Mr. Krenshaw,
Mr. Joyce, Mr. Joyce votes no. Mr.
Weber, Mr. Weber votes no. Mr. Allen,
Mr. Allen votes no. Mr. Balderson, Mr.
Balderson votes no. Mr. Fulture. Mr.
Fulture votes no. Mr. Fluger, Mr. Fluger
votes no. Mrs. Harshburgger, Mrs.
Harshburgger votes no. Mrs. Miller
Meeks, Mrs. Mrs. Miller makes me votes
no. Mrs. Kamik
Mrs. Kamik votes no. Mr. Obernolulti.
Mr. James.
Mr. Bence. Mr. Bence votes no. Mrs.
Hchin. Mrs. Hchin votes no. Mr. Fry.
Miss. Lee. Miss Lee votes no. Mr.
Langworthy. Mr. Langworthy votes no. Mr.
Kain.
>> Mr. Kane votes no. Mr. Rley.
>> Mr. Mr. Rley votes no. Mr. Evans. Mr.
Evans votes no. Mr. Goldman. Mr. Goldman
votes no. Mrs. Fedorch. Mrs. Fedorch
votes no. Mr. Palone.
Mr. Palone votes I. Mr. Gette.
>> Hi.
>> Mr. Gette votes I. Miss Shakowski.
>> Yes.
>> Miss Shakowski votes I. Miss Matsui.
>> Miss Matsui votes I. Miss Caster. Miss
Caster votes I. Mr. Tonko. I
>> Mr. Tonka votes I Miss Clark Miss Clark
votes I Mr. Ruiz Mr. Ruiz votes I Mr.
Peters Mr. Peters votes I Mrs. Dingle
Mrs. Dingle votes I Mr. Vzy Mr. Vzy
votes I Miss Kelly Miss Kelly votes I
Miss Baragon
Mr. Sodto Mr. Sodto votes I. Miss
Shrier. Miss Shrier votes I. Miss
Treyanne. Miss Treyan. Votes I. Miss
Fletcher.
>> Miss Fletcher votes I. Miss
Aassiocortez.
Miss Aassiocortez votes I. Mr. Aenclaus.
Mr. Aenclaus votes I.
Mr. Carter of Louisiana. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana votes I. Mr. Menendez. Mr.
Menendez votes I. Mr. Mullen. Mr. Mullen
votes I. Mr. Mr. Lansman. Mr. Lansman
votes I. Miss Mlullen. Miss Mlullen
votes I. Mr. Guthrie
>> no.
>> Mr. Guthrie votes no.
>> Mr. Hudson.
>> Mr. Hudson votes no.
>> Anyone seeking recognition on our side?
On the other side.
>> Seeing none, the clerk will report the
results.
Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 23
eyes and 25 nos.
>> The amendment is not agreed to. Are
there further amendments? Gentleman from
Louisiana. What purp you seek
recognition?
>> Mr. Chairman, I have an amendment at the
desk.
>> The clerk will report. FC
AMD HR9317_01
>> clerk report
>> amendment to HR 9317 offered by Mr.
Carter of Louisiana page two line nine
strike
>> without objection the reading of the
amendment is dispensed with and
gentleman from Louisiana is recognized
for five minutes in support of the
amendment
>> thank you Mr. Chairman, you know, I I
think we have stooped to one of our
lowest lows today. Mr. line worthy. Your
disingenuous and disgraceful attempt
to hide behind
disabled children as if
idling buses and forcing them to breathe
these horrible fumes
is somehow the right thing to do.
Republicans, Democrats, and the like
should be disgusted by this veile
attempt to expose our young people to
these harmful fumes. The American people
aren't stupid. They can listen to this
argument saying, "Let's we need to have
more time for these buses to idle so we
can help this child get on the bus." My
god, turn the bus off.
Turn the bus off.
I have serious concerns about HR 9317,
the buses act. Let's be honest about
what this bill actually does. It doesn't
set a minimum standard. It sets a
pollution floor. It forces every state
in every city in this country to allow
buses to idle for at least 15 minutes
before any restriction can apply. 15
minutes of diesel exhaust pumped into
the air and into our children's lungs.
Our families breathe this every day.
Mandated by federal law. This bill
doesn't stop there. It strips states of
the tools to enforce their own clean air
protections. It bans citizens
enforcement mechanism. And it blocks any
civil action against owners or operators
for viol violating engine idling
restrictions.
This is big government reaching into our
cities and telling them they can no
longer protect their residents from air
pollution. In the French Quarter in my
hometown and district of New Orleans,
one of the busiest, most tourist heavy
neighborhoods in the country, the city
limits busing bus idling to just 10
minutes. That's a local government
making local making local judgment about
local health. It keeps dense, hightraic
tourist corridors breathable for
residents, workers, and visitors alike.
Under this bill, that protection could
be wiped out.
The science is clear. Diesel exhaust is
serious respiratory hazard. It's linked
to asthma attacks, cardiovascular
strain, and long-term lung damage,
particularly for our most vulnerable
children who have developing lungs, the
elderly, the people who are pre-existing
conditions. Local idling restrictions
exist because communities look at their
own streets, bus depots, school pickup
lines, and decided their residents
deserve better air. This bill takes
those protections away. New Orleans no
longer can decide how long diesel idles
that engines can idle in the French
Quarter or beyond. No matter how many
tourists, how many workers are nearby,
how many residents and children have to
breathe this. This amendment preserves
local authority where it matters most.
My amendment would allow states and
localities to continue enacting idling
restrictions for buses operating with
100 within 100 ft of a school, daycare
facility, nursing home, or hospital, or
other healthc care facilities.
Regardless of this bill's federal
15minute floor,
these are exactly the locations where
our most vulnerable populations,
children, seniors, and patients already
are dealing with illnesses. are are con
and are concentrated most susceptible to
health harms of diesel exhaust. If this
body insists on national idling
standards, the least we can do is ensure
it doesn't strip protections from the
doorstep of our schools and hospitals. I
would urge you, Mr. lang worthy to check
your conscience,
to adjust your thought, to recognize
that we aren't stupid, to recognize the
American people would not allow you to
hide your veil attempt to protect an
industry that wants to choke our
children and to stand behind a disabled
child to do it. Shame on you. Shame on
you. I yield.
>> Mr. Chairman, do we really have to have
these personal attacks? So, it
>> wasn't personal, sir.
>> The gentleman's going to be recognized.
So, you yield back. So, gentleman's
going to be recognized to be able to
respond.
>> Um,
>> gentleman from New York recognized for
five minutes.
>> Thank you very much, Mr. Chairman. You
know, they they all say turn the bus
off. The safety checks, the wheelchair
lifts, all those things require the bus
to be on. I mean, they they're just
denying that. And I just asked a
gentleman
today, I think in New Orleans there's a
100 degree heat index. How many of the
school kids do you want to sit on that
bus while the heat turns up? Um, is is
that is that taking care of kids?
>> Will the gentleman yield since you asked
me a question?
>> Certainly.
>> Yeah. I don't want them to stand. I
don't want him to be in it at all. And I
also don't want them to breathe
additional fumes. Do you realize that
the toxins from that bus isn't going to
make it cooler, my friend? It's going to
make it hotter. Wh why this bill is
important is because a bounty hunter
style program was put in place by the
city of New York trying to vilify
hardworking bus drivers and trying to
penalize them so people can put personal
profit in their pocket. So I it has
absolutely put these drivers in a
terrible position uh to have to to race
to meet these clocks and maybe 6 months
down the road get a complaint against
them because someone decided to take an
iPhone video of a bus that went 2
minutes over their allotted time. uh the
the absolute theatrics on the other side
of the aisle, the personal attacks and
the vitriol is wildly unnecessary and uh
is shameful in your own right, sir. So,
I yield back, Mr. Chairman.
Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion on the amendment? Gentle lady
from gentle lady from New York is
recognized for five minutes. Gentlemen,
Miss Clark from New York is recognized
for five minutes.
>> Thank you very much, Mr. Chairman. I
move to strike the lights blast.
>> The ladies recognize and speak on the
>> I'd like to speak in support of this
amendment. In the Northeast, where
communities of color breathe 66% more
air pollution from vehicles than their
white neighbors, diseases ranging from
heart disease to asthma are becoming
dangerously exacerbated and the
individuals suffering from them.
Brownsville, Brooklyn, which is within
my congressional district, has the
highest adult asthma rates out of any
neighborhood in New York City and across
the US. Minorities are the majority who
are impacted by this painful illness.
Black children, in particular, have the
highest number of asthma attacks among
all ethnic groups and are 10 times more
likely than their white peers to suffer
from asthma. According to the American
Lung Association,
these tragic figures and facts didn't
happen by accident. This is a direct
line between the systemic inequities and
racism that shape our transportation and
investment policies. It is essential
that cities like New York are able to
uphold strong standards and safeguards
for vulnerable communities that are
often located nearby frequently
transport transportation routes. That is
why I support this common sense
amendment that seeks to protect
vulnerable committees like, excuse me,
communities like children and the
elderly from increased exposure to
diesel exhaust and allow states and
localities to enact more health
protective engine ugling restrictions
when near a school, daycare, nursing
home or hospital. With that, I urge
adoption of this amendment. And I'd like
to also just say to the gentleman from
New York, what's it to you?
What is it to you? You're not from New
York City. This is very specific to the
city of New York. Why is this a problem
for you? Our communities have had to
suffer from asthma, from heart disease.
Yet you have found a reason to go after
these communities that have found a
solution to a problem that has been
plaguing our communities for generations
now. With that, I'm just going to yield
uh to the gentle lady from New York.
>> Thank you. And I'd like to underscore uh
the gentle lady's points. What I I again
what I do not understand is that the
gentleman proposing these changes and
describing what is happening in New York
City represents New York's 23rd
congressional district, Erie County. You
cannot get closer to Canada.
You cannot get closer to Canada than
Erie County and the Congressman's
District.
you can hardly get further away from New
York City than the congressman's
district. And so I understand that uh
the congress I understand the
congressman's unfamiliarity with the
provision and the lack of knowledge
around the provision. But that is why we
ask that you yield to the individuals
who actually represent these
communities. We work with these bus
drivers. I work for them. I make sure
that they're safe just as much as I make
sure their kids are safe. I assure you
they are not being penalized because
common sense provisions exist in this
bill. And for the not the first, not the
second, but the third time when
presented with evidence showing that
that these claims are outlandish, we're
still seeing this insistence on
something that's not true. So what we
don't understand here is what is with
the energy with targeting New York City
and South Bronx kids because this
provision only targets we're here at at
the federal level targeting a program
that ex exists for one municipality in
the entirety of the United States
designed for one specific community and
municipality in the entire United
States. We're not trying to force these
reporting requirements on anybody else,
but we know that they're necessary so
our kids can no longer have the highest
asthma rates in the country. In the
country. So, it's not designed for
communities that do not struggle with
this issue, but we want to make sure
that our kids excel, that our bus
drivers are safe. Those carveouts, I
assure you, from the Bronx are there.
drivers are not being penalized for
loading kids and and having safety
provisions. And once again, we don't
think that laws for the South Bronx
should be dictated, described, or or
written for people who literally
represent areas that could not get close
to Canada, could not be closer to
Canada. So, respectfully, let us do our
thing and protect our kids. Thank you
very much.
>> I yield back, Mr. Chairman.
>> Gentle lady yields back. Is there
further discussion?
gentleman from uh Texas is recognized
for five minutes.
>> Thank you. I yield to the gentleman from
New York.
>> Thank you very much u for yielding the
time. Thank you for the recognition, Mr.
Chairman. You're absolutely correct. I
don't I don't live in New York City. Um
the the idea about New York City
policies, and I've certainly spent
plenty of time in both of your
districts. I'm very familiar with your
city and its laws and how bad they are
and how contagious they become to other
copycats around the country. And that's
why we have to take federal action. I
mean, yes, I I do not live in your
district, but uh it doesn't stop you
from opining about how we should heat
our homes in my district. You have
plenty of opinions about how the entire
state should govern itself and how you
have absolutely zero concept of what the
lifestyle is. I mean, sometimes you
travel around to those places and
campaign for candidates, and you
certainly, you know, do a lot of tourism
outside of your own district, but let's
let's face facts. These are issues when
they start in New York or they start in
California, they get contagious and go
around the country. We want to stop a
bounty hunter program from vilifying bus
drivers that happen to go over a certain
limit so people can create an industry
for themselves to make money off of the
back of of these bus drivers and these
companies that are trying to do their
job and take care of the people that
they're there to transport. I yield
back.
>> Gentleman from Texas
>> yield yields back. Is there further
discussion?
Seeing none, the question occurs on the
amendment. A roll call has been
requested and the clerk will call the
role.
>> Mr. Lada.
>> Mr. Lada votes no. Mr. Griffith.
>> Mr. Griffith votes no. Mr. Bill Rockus.
>> Mr. Bill Rockus votes no. Mr. Hudson.
>> Mr. Carter of Georgia.
>> Mr. Carter of Georgia votes no. Mr.
Palmer.
Mr. Pal Mr. Palmer votes no. Mr. Dunn.
Mr. Crrenshaw
Mr. Joyce Mr. Joyce votes no Mr. Weber
Mr. Weber votes no Mr. Allen Mr. Allen
votes no Mr. Balderson
Mr. Balderson votes no Mr. Fulture Mr.
Fulture votes no Mr. Fluger
Mr. Fluger votes no Mrs. Harshburgger
Mrs. Harshburgger votes no Mrs. Mrs.
Miller Meeks
Mrs. Miller Meeks votes no Mrs. Kamik
Mrs. Kamik votes no Mr. Obernalty
Mr. James
Mr. Bence Mr. Bence votes no Mrs. Hchin
Mrs. Hchin votes no Mr. Fry
Mr. Fry votes no Miss Lee Miss Lee votes
no Mr. Langworthy
>> Mr. Mr. Langworthy votes no. Mr. Kane.
>> Mr. Kane votes no. Mr. Ruly.
>> Mr. Rley votes no. Mr. Evans. Mr. Evans
votes no. Mr. Goldman. Mr. Goldman votes
no. Mrs. Fedorch.
Mrs. Fedorch votes no. Mr. Palone. Mr.
Palone votes I. Miss Dette. Miss Dette
votes I. Miss. Shakowski.
>> I.
>> Miss Shakowski votes I. Miss Matsui
>> Miss Matsui votes I. Miss Caster I.
>> Miss Caster votes I. Mr. Tonko
>> I.
>> Mr. Tonka votes I. Miss. Clark.
>> Miss. Clark votes I. Mr. Ruiz. Mr. Ruiz
votes I. Mr. Peters. Mr. Peters votes I.
Mrs. Dingle. Mrs. Dingle votes I. Mr.
Vzy.
Mr. Vy votes I. Miss. Kelly. Miss. Kelly
votes I.................... Miss. Baron.
Mr. Sodto. Mr. Sodto votes I. Miss
Shrier.
Miss Shrier. Vote.
Miss Shrier votes I. Miss Treyan. Miss
Treyan votes I. Miss Fletcher.
Miss Fletcher votes I. Miss
Accassiocortez. Miss Accassiocortez
votes I. Mr. Aenclaus. Mr. Aenclaus
votes I. Mr. Carter of Louisiana. Mr.
Carter of Louisiana votes I. Mr.
Menendez. Mr. Menendez votes I. Mr.
Mullen. Mr. Mullen votes I. Mr. Lansman.
Mr. Lansman votes I. Miss. Mlen. Mr.
Mlen votes I. Mr. Guthrie. Mr. Guthrie
votes no. Mr. Hudson is not recorded.
Mr. Hudson votes no.
>> The clerk will report.
Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 23
eyes and 26 nos.
>> The amendment is not agreed to. Are
there further amendments,
>> Mr. Chair?
>> Oh, the gentleman from New York is
recognized.
>> Uh, what purpose? A gentleman from what
purposes? Gentleman from New York
recognition.
>> I have an amendment at the desk. It's
labeled HR9317_3.
>> The clerk will report.
>> Amendment to HR 9317 offered by Mr.
Tonko. Add at the end the following
section three limitation. This act
including the amendments made by this
act shall not take effect. Without
objection, the reading amendment is
dispensed with and gentleman from New
York is recognized for 5 minutes as
support of the amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chair. President Trump's
reckless and illegal war with Iran is
burdening Americans with persistently
high fuel prices. Since February, each
American has paid hundreds of dollars
more for gas and others uh and others
and other goods. And thanks to President
Trump including a combined $41 billion
at the pump for their gasoline. And the
nationwide average for diesel fuel is
currently over $5.60 per gallon.
Americans have paid more than $34
billion in higher diesel prices since
the start of the war. And that affects
everyone whether they drive a diesel
vehicle or not. Diesel is used to power
our freight industry, which means an
extra $34 billion to move food and goods
around the country, which is being
passed on to Americans in higher grocery
prices. It is clear that President Trump
has completely failed to understand the
ramic ramifications of his decisions,
including how this war will be impacting
the global economy for years to come.
And unfortunately, the buses act would
double down on this failure since most
of our buses use diesel. Anti- idling
laws protect public health. We heard
today of the benefits that are brought
the way of our children and certainly uh
those anti-tling laws are addressing
unnecessary air pollution and they also
reduce wasted fuel. Argon National
Laboratory has found that idling in the
United States wastes more than six
billion uh six billion gallons of fuel
per year. At this time of high fuel
prices, we should not be doing anything
that will worsen the situation for
Americans wallets. In fact, lowering
demand by reducing wasted fuel is a very
sensible immediate action that could
help relieve pressure on everyone who is
paying more at the pump or having costs
passed on to them at the grocery store.
So, this amendment is simple. It
prevents the buses act from taking
effect until the EPA administrator finds
it will not increase spending on fueling
costs for Americans. We cannot afford to
jump from one reckless policy to
another. Let's take the time to figure
out whether the buses act will worsen
the current pain at the pump before we
allow more diesel fuel to be wasted.
Let's do right by our kids. Let's do
right by our communities. And let's do
right by our environment. With that, I
urge members to support this amendment,
Mr. there and I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields. Do is there any other
member who wishes to speak on the
amendment?
>> Seeing none, a roll call has been
requested. The clerk will call the role.
>> Mr. Lada. Mr. Lada votes no. Mr.
Griffith. Mr. Griffith votes no. Mr.
Bill Rockus.
Mr. Bill Rockus votes no. Mr. Hudson.
Mr. Carter of Georgia.
>> Mr. Carter of Georgia votes no. Mr.
Palmer. Mr. Palmer votes no. Mr. Dunn.
Mr. Krenshaw.
Mr. Joyce.
Mr. Joyce votes no. Mr. Weber. Mr. Weber
votes no. Mr. Allen. Mr. Allen votes no.
Mr. Balderson. Mr. Balderson votes no.
Mr. Fulture. Mr. Fulture votes no. Mr.
Fluger
Mrs. Harshburgger Mrs. Harshburgger
votes no Mrs. Miller Meeks
Mrs. Kamik
Mrs. Kamik votes no Mr. Obernalty
Mr. James
Mr. Bence Mr. Bence votes no Mrs. Hchin
Mrs. Hchin votes no Mr. Fry Mr. Fry
votes no. Miss Lee, Miss Lee votes no.
Mr. Langworthy.
>> Mr. Langworthy votes no. Mr. Kane. Mr.
Kane votes no. Mr. Roelly.
>> Mr. Roelly votes no. Mr. Evans. Mr.
Evans votes no. Mr. Goldman. Mr. Goldman
votes no. Mrs. Fedorch.
Mr. Palone. Mr. Palone votes I. Miss
Dette. Miss Dette votes I. Miss
Shakowski. I
>> Miss Shakowski votes I. Miss Matts Suie
>> I.
>> Miss Matt Suie votes I. Miss Caster.
Miss Caster votes I. Mr. Tonko.
>> I.
>> Mr. Tonko votes I. Miss. Clark. Miss.
Clark votes I. Mr. Ruiz. Mr. Ruiz votes
I. Mr. Peters. Mr. Peters votes I. Mrs.
Dingle.
Mrs. Dingle votes I. Mr. Vzy.
Mr. Vzy votes I. Ms. Kelly. Miss Kelly
votes I. Miss Baragon Miss Baragon votes
I. Mr. Sodto Mr. Sodto votes I. Miss
Shrier. Miss Shrier votes I. Miss
Treyan.
Miss Treyan votes I. Miss Fletcher. Miss
Fletcher votes I. Miss Aassiocortez.
Miss Aassiocortez votes I. Mr. Aenclaus.
Mr. Aenclaus votes I. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana.
Mr. Carter of Louisiana votes I. Mr.
Mendez. Mr. Menendez votes I. Mr.
Mullen.
Mr. Lansman. Mr. Lansman votes I. Miss.
Mlen.
Miss. Mlen votes I. Mr. Guth. Mr.
Guthrie. Mr. Guthrie votes no.
Mr. Krenshaw votes no.
Mr. Hudson votes no.
Mr. Fleer about to know
>> he was right there.
How is Mr. Guthrie recorded?
>> Mr. Mr. Guthrie is recorded as no.
>> Okay. The clerk may uh report the total.
Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 23
eyes and 25 nos.
>> The amendment is not agreed to. Are
there any other amendments?
Okay, we will now have a a recorded vote
on on final passage of of the bill. The
clerk will call the role.
Mr. Lada Mr. Lada votes I. Mr. Griffith
Mr. Griffith votes I. Mr. Bill Rockus
Mr. Bill Rockus votes I. Mr. Hudson
Mr. Carter of Georgia Mr. Carter of
Georgia votes I. Mr. Palmer. Mr. Palmer
votes I. Mr. Dunn.
Mr. Krenshaw.
Mr. Joyce. Mr. Joyce votes I. Mr. Weber,
Mr. Allen,
Mr. Allen votes I. Mr. Balderson, Mr.
Balderson votes I. Mr. Fulture, Mr.
Fulture votes I. Mr. Fluger,
Mrs. Harshburgger, Mrs. Harshburgger
votes I. Mrs. Miller Meeks, Mrs. Kamik,
Mrs. Kamik votes I. Mr. Obernolulti,
Mr. James,
Mr. Mr. Bence. Mr. Bence votes I. Mrs.
Hchen. Mrs. Hchen votes I. Mr. Fry. Mr.
Fry votes I. Miss Lee. Miss Lee votes I.
Mr. Langworthy. Mr. Langworthy votes I.
Mr. Kaine. Mr. Kane votes I. Mr. Roelly.
>> Mr. Roelly votes I. Mr. Evans. Mr. Evans
votes I. Mr. Goldman. Mr. Goldman votes
I. Mrs. Fedorch.
>> Mr. Palone. Mr. Palone votes no. Miss
Dette Mette votes no. Miss Shakowski.
Miss Shakowski votes no. Miss Matsui.
Miss Matsui votes no. Miss Caster. Miss
Caster votes no. Mr. Tonko.
>> No.
>> Mr. Tonko votes no. Miss. Clark. Miss.
Clark votes no. Mr. Ruiz. Mr. Ruiz votes
no. Mr. Peters. Mr. Peters votes I. Mrs.
Dingle.
Mr. Mrs. Dingle votes no. Mr. Vzy Mr.
Vzy votes no. Mrs. Kell Misss Kelly Miss
Kelly votes no. Miss Baron Miss Bargon
votes no. Mr. Sodto Mr. Sodto votes I.
Miss Shrier.
Miss Shrier votes no. Miss Trean. Miss
Trean votes no. Miss Fletcher. Miss
Fletcher votes no. Miss Aassio Cortez.
Miss Sakasiocortez votes no. Mr.
Aenclaus, Mr. Aenclaus votes no. Mr.
Carter of Louisiana. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana votes no. Mr. Mendez, Mr.
Menendez votes no. Mr. Mullen.
Mr. Lansman. Mr. Lansman votes no. Miss
Mlullen. Miss Mlullen votes no. Mr.
Guthrie. Mr. Guthrie votes I.
>> Is anyone seeking? How's Mr. Fluger
recorded?
>> Mr. Fluger votes I.
>> Mr. Hudson.
>> Mr. Hudson votes I.
>> Mr. Krenshaw.
>> Mr. Krenshaw votes.
>> Weber.
>> Mr. Weber votes I.
>> Mr. Sodto.
>> Mr. Vodto is off. I on. No.
>> Is there anyone else seeking
recognition? If not, the clerk will
report.
Mr. Mr. Chairman, on that vote there
were 26 eyes's and 22 nos.
>> The bill is agreed to is adopted. I'm
sorry. The bill is adopted. So the chair
calls up HR 9615 and ask the clerk to
report.
>> HR 9615,
a bill to support the recycling and
recovery.
>> Without objection, the first reading of
the bill is dispensed with and bill open
for amendment at any point. So ordered.
Does anyone seek recognition to speak on
the bill?
The gentleman from Alabama is recognized
for five minutes to speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Um, this
legislation, the Brace Act, is a
bipartisan bill to strengthen America's
domestic battery recycling industry and
recover critical minerals already in our
country. would like to thank u my
colleagues across the aisle,
Representatives Menendez and Rez for uh
co-sponsoring this this bill. Demand for
lithium ion batteries has grown
exponentially driven by electric
vehicles, energy storage,
communications, and consumer products.
As these batteries reach the end of
their lives, recycling can recover
valuable critical minerals, including
lithium, cobalt, nickel, and copper. Yet
much of this material is sent overseas
often to China for processing. Our
current RCRA regulations which predate
the widespread use of lithium ion
batteries create unnecessary cost and
uncertainty for recyclers. The Brace Act
will allow destination facilities to
store lithium ion batteries at the same
location where they are recycled,
eliminating unnecessary cost or the need
for complex permits.
These common sense updates will help
grow domestic battery recycling and
strengthen our critical mineral supply
chain. I urge my colleagues to support
the bill and I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back and the gentleman
from California is recognized for five
minutes to speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I'm proud to be
a Democratic co-lead of this bipartisan
bill with my colleagues, Representative
Drs. Miller Meeks and Representative
Menendez. As a demand for lithium ion
batteries grows, we cannot afford to
keep treating used batteries as waste to
be landfilled or shipped overseas.
Here is where the problem lies. The
rules governing these batteries at the
end of their life were written for a
different era of technology. EPA's
universal waste program, the streamlined
system that's supposed to make recycling
batteries easier, was built around lead
acid and nickel cadmium batteries. It
was never designed for lithium ion
chemistry, and it shows these rules do
not reflect how lithium ion batteries
need to be handled, stored, and kept
safe from fire. The EPA has been working
since 2023 to build a new regulatory
category specifically for lithium
batteries because the current rules
leaves recyclers guessing and fail to
address the real risks such as fires,
prolonged fires that this technology
poses. The Brace Act sets storage
standards for destination recycling
facilities that are built for lithium
ion batteries, not borrowed from decades
old rules for a different chemistry.
That means domestic recyclers finally
get standards that match reality so they
can recover critical materials like
lithium, cobalt, and nickel right here
at home instead of watching that value
and those jobs walk out the door to
foreign competitors. California's 25th
district is home to lithium valley, the
largest known lithium deposit in North
America, fifth largest in the world. My
district is on the front lines of
building America's domestic battery
supply chain using direct lithium
extraction to pull the raw material that
powers this technology out of the brine
in the geothermal uh region uh down
below uh filtering the lithium out. Uh
because right now we are only building
half the supply chain. We need to
dramatically increase our own domestic
supplies of batteries and we need to do
better at recycling our batteries that
we manufacture. The Brace Act finishes
the job by giving us the capacity to
recycle and recover these materials at
the end of life too. Turning what could
become a growing waste problem into good
paying jobs. real economic opportunity
and long-term investment in a region
that has been overlooked for too long.
Strong recycling infrastructure means
the jobs stay here, the tax base stays
here, and the materials stay here
instead of getting shipped overseas,
processed, and sold back to us as a
markup. I urge my colleagues to support
HR 9615, and I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion? Gentleman from Pennsylvania
is recognized for five minutes to speak
on the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Recently, I had
the opportunity to visit McDermad
Alpha's metal recycling facility in my
district in Altuna, Pennsylvania. This
facility recycles solder and recovers
electronics grade metals to return into
the supply chain. Legislation like the
brace act that we are considering now
will help push EPA to modernize
regulations so that recyclers that want
to recover critical materials can
operate successfully as McDermad Alpha
is doing right here in the United States
today. The US does not produce the
volume of critical materials necessary
to supply the needs of an advanced
economy. This problem will only get
worse as we introduce new technology
both in industry and in our daily lives.
Even more troubling is the fact that
current legislation and regulations
stand in the way of recycling and
reusing these materials once they have
entered our supply chain. As we work to
build our ability to process critical
materials, growing our battery recycling
capabilities will help bridge the
domestic supply gap that we currently
are facing. From the phone that's in
your pocket to the Starlink satellites
in orbit that connect you to the rest of
the world, critical materials are
necessary for all of our modern
technologies that power and improve our
daily lives. This is an important issue.
I applaud my colleague, Representative
Miller Meeks, for her work on this
bipartisan legislation and I thank
Chairman Guthrie for including this bill
in our markup today. Thank you and I
yield back.
>> The gentleman yields back. Is there
further disc? Gentleman from New Jersey
is recognized for five minutes to speak
on the bill.
>> Thank you, chairman. The Battery
Recycling for America's Competitive
Economy Act or Brace Act is a bipartisan
compromise that offers a practical win
for both the environment and our
domestic supply chain. Lithium ion
batteries power everything from electric
vehicles to smartphones to gridscale
energy storage. As demand for these
resources grows, so does the need to
recover and reuse the materials we
already have in circulation so we can
reduce waste, conserve critical
minerals, and mitigate the environmental
impacts associated with their
extraction. It is also an important
supply chain issue as China dominates
the critical mineral supply chains that
support clean energy, advanced
technology, and our national defense.
Building domestic recycling capacity can
help keep valuable materials here in the
United States. The Brace Act provides a
negotiated path forward to support
lithium ion battery recycling while
maintaining meaningful safeguards for
workers in surrounding communities. It
would create parody between facilities
that temporarily store lithium ion
batteries before recycling and recyclers
who store battery waste on site. and it
would introduce additional safety and
management requirements for those
recyclers while the EPA develops a rule.
Critically, the bill directs the EPA to
promptly issue muchneeded lithium ion
specific regulations that provide
solutions for the unique safety and
environmental risk these batteries pose.
And it requires the EPA to consider
necessary safety protections as part of
that rulemaking, which is vital given
the fire hazards that lithium ion
batteries can pose. This bill pushes the
EPA to establish clear standards to
protect workers and fence line
communities, reduce waste, and
strengthen our critical mineral supply
chains. There's more work ahead, but
this bill is an important first step
toward a safer, more circular, and more
resilient battery economy. I urge my
colleagues to both support both the
amendment and the underlying bill. I
yield back.
>> The gentleman yields back. Is there
further discussion on the bill? Seeing
none, are there any amendments? The
gentleman from Alabama. What purpose do
you seek recognition?
>> Mr. Chairman, have an amendment at the
desk.
>> Identify the amendment.
Is it FC Ames uh
961501?
Clerk report that amendment
>> amendment in the nature of a substitute
to the committee print for HR 9615.
>> Without objection, reading amendment is
dispensed with and gentleman is
recognized for five minutes in support
of the amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I'm pleased to
offer an amendment to the bill that
contains a small technical clarification
and correction to the referenced Code of
Federal Regulations provisions. We
greatly appreciate the time that the
battery and recycling industries, waste
management law experts, and NOS's have
spent reviewing this bill and providing
feedback. The minor revisions in
sections 2B of the bill clarify that
interim requirements under this bill
that allow battery recycling facilities
or designation facilities to temporarily
store batteries prior to recycling would
apply to battery recycling facilities
that handle both small and large
quantities of universal waste.
Additionally, this amendment corrects
one reference to the EPA's universal
waste regulations. Both the majority and
minority have provided input on this
amendment in line with the bipartisan
spirit of this bill. These small changes
ensure Congress's directives are clear.
I encourage my colleagues to support
this amendment. I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion on the amendment? Seeing
none, the question occurs on the
amendment. All those in favor will vote
I. I. Of those opposed, no. The eyes
have it. The amendment is agreed to. Are
there further amendments? Seeing none,
the question now occurs on adopting HR
9615 as amended. A roll call has been
requested and the clerk will call the
role.
>> Mr. Lada.
>> Mr. Lau votes I. Mr. Griffith Mr.
Griffith votes I. Mr. Bill Rockus.
Mr. Hudson.
Mr. Carter of Georgia.
Mr. Palmer.
Mr. Palmer votes I. Mr. Dunn.
>> Mr. Mr. Crrenshaw,
Mr. Joyce,
Mr. Weber,
Mr. Allen,
Mr. Allen votes I. Mr. Balderson,
Mr. Fulture,
Mr. Fulture votes I. Mr. Fluger,
Mrs. Harshburgger,
Mrs. Harshburgger votes I. Mrs. Miller
Meeks,
Mrs. Kamik,
Mr. Obernolulti,
Mr. James,
Mr. Bence, Mr. Bence votes I.
Mrs. Hchin,
Mr. Fry,
Mr. Fry votes I. Miss Lee, Miss Lee
votes I. Mr. Langworthy. Mr. Mr.
Langworthy votes I. Mr. Kaine. Mr. Kane
votes I. Mr. Roelly.
Mr. Evans.
Mr. Evans votes I. Mr. Goldman.
Mrs. Fedorch.
Mr. Palone.
Mr. Palone votes I. Mr. Dette.
Mr. Dette votes I. Miss Shakowski.
Miss Shakowski votes I. Miss Matsuie.
Miss Mattsuie votes I. Miss Caster. Miss
Caster votes I. Mr. Tonko.
Mr. Tonko votes I. Miss. Clark. Miss.
Clark votes I. Mr. Ruiz.
Mr. Ruiz votes I. Mr. Peters.
Mrs. Dingle.
Mrs. Miss Dingle votes I. Mr. VC Mr. VC
votes I. Miss Kelly. Miss Kelly votes I.
Miss Baron.
Mr. Sodto. Mr. Sodto votes I. Miss
Shrier. Miss Shrier votes I. Miss.
Trean. Miss. Trean. Votes I. Miss.
Fletcher. Miss Fletcher votes I. Miss
Aassiocortez.
Mr. Aenclauss.
Mr. Aenclaus votes I. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana. Mr. Carter of Louisiana votes
I. Mr. Mendez. Mr. Mendez votes I. Mr.
Mullen.
Mr. Lansman.
Miss. Mlullen.
Ms. Mcclullen votes I. Mr. Guthrie. Mr.
Guthrie votes I.
I
>> Mr. Bill Rockus votes I.
>> Mr. Carter
>> I.
>> Mr. Carter of Georgia votes I.
>> Dr. Joyce
>> I
>> Mr. Joyce votes I.
>> Mr. Roelly.
>> Mr. Roelly votes I.
>> Mr.
>> Balderson.
>> Mr. Balderson votes I.
>> Miss Fedorch
>> I.
>> Miss Fedor votes I.
>> Miss Bagon.
>> Miss Baragon votes I.
>> Dr. Ruiz.
>> Mr. Mr. Ruiz votes I.
>> Mr. Peters.
>> Mr. Cassiocortez.
>> Mr. Casiocortez votes I.
>> Are there any other people? Oh, Mr.
Goldman.
>> Mr. Goldman votes I.
>> Oh, Mr. Krenshaw.
>> Mr. Krenshaw votes I.
>> M. Mr. Lansman. Oh, Krenshaw.
Wait, let's stop. All right. So, we got
Mr. Krenshaw, right?
>> So, Mr. Hudson
>> Hudson vows.
>> Mr. Hudson bows eye.
Miss Hchen.
>> Miss Hchin votes I.
>> Mr. Lansman.
>> I.
>> Mr. Lansman votes.
>> Yeah. Okay. I'm sorry.
>> That was dramatic.
>> It's a dramatic pause. Any other people
seeking the clerk report?
The clerk report.
Mr. Chairman, on that vote, there were
46 eyes and zero nos.
>> The eyes have it. The bill is adopted.
The chair calls up HR 3978 and ask the
clerk to report
>> HR 3978,
a bill to amend the definition of
production facility. Without objection,
uh the reading of the bill is dispensed
with and the bill open for amendment at
any point. So ordered. Does anyone seek
to be recognized and speak on the bill?
>> You can do you can do it from here.
Okay, there we go.
I don't do that. Thank you.
>> The chair recognizes himself for five
minutes to speak on the bill.
HR 3978 would clarify an atomic energy
act definition of a production facility
to exclude spent fuel reprocessing
facilities bringing them in line with
the licensing framework of other fuel
cycle re facilities. A strong and robust
domestic nuclear fuel cycle is a
paramount is paramount to maintaining
and growing nuclear capacity in the
United States. The deployment of
advanced reactors and the operation of
our existing fleet cannot be done
without access to an abundant secure
fuel supply.
Efficient licensing of reprocessing
facilities as this bill ensures advances
our policy to maximize access to the
additional energy as well as isotopes
available in spent nuclear fuel. The
nuclear fuel refuel acts supports this
goal by clarifying that spent fuel
reprocessing fence facilities will be
licensed under the same framework as
other fuel cycle facilities rather than
production facilities which require a
longer two-step process for licensing
more appropriate for nuclear reactors.
We strengthen this bill during our
subcommittee market by clarifying that
only reprocessing facilities that do not
isolate plutonium are excluded from the
definition of production facility and
that requirements pertaining to the
export of reprocessing facilities remain
unchanged. Both changes maintain the
goal of the bill while ensuring strong
non-prololiferation barriers are
maintained. The bill will ensure
industry has efficient licensing path to
deploy spent fuel reprocessing while
maintaining all necessary requirements
to asssure adequate protection of the
public. I want to thank my co our
colleague the gentleman from
California's 50th district for his work
on the legislation and I urge my
colleagues to support this legislation.
I yield back the balance of my time and
the chair now recognizes the gentleman
from California's 50th district for five
minutes to speak on the bill. Thank you,
Mr. Chairman. Uh, nuclear is an
emissionsfree and base load power source
that is and can be a critical part of
our generation mix, especially as energy
demand continues to rise. I have to
emphasize we we have to continue to work
to do the work we we are doing on a
durable path for interim and long-term
storage and utilization of nuclear
waste. We need need to get it off the
coast at places like Saninophre and
areas where the science tells us it's
safe to go, not just where the politics
allowed. Meanwhile, we should also
encourage innovation and advanced
nuclear that can generate power while
producing less waste. We can continue to
invest in nuclear technologies that use
nucle use waste as a power source, which
is the focus of this bill, the nuclear
refuel act. One key aspect of our
nuclear strategy that has consistently
been ignored as we build new nuclear
power is a solution to this question of
nuclear waste, specifically the
long-term storage of spent nuclear fuel.
This doesn't have to be an eitheror. We
need to regain our ability to build
nuclear power in this country as we move
toward a solution for nuclear waste. To
do that, we have to remove barriers to
recycling and other advanced uses for
spent fuels. That's why the Nuclear
Refuel Act is such a solid first step.
I'm glad the committee is moving moving
it on to the floor. Making it easier to
recycle and reuse spent fuel keeps it in
reactors and away from communities. It
also helps us keep a good reliable
supply chain of fuel which is good for
national security. I want to thank Chair
Lada, Chair Guthrie, and Ranking Member
Palone and their staffs for working hard
to ensure the Nuclear Refuel Act could
be considered and advanced during
today's markup. While this bill is only
one component of a larger, more
comprehensive solution to what we do
with spent nuclear fuel, I urge my
colleagues to support it because it
gives us another tool in our toolbox
without sacrificing safety or oversight.
And I yield back. Thank you. The
gentleman yields back. The chair now
recognizes the gentleman from Idaho's
first district. Five minutes to speak on
the bill. Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
Strike last word.
The gentleman's recognized. Thank you. I
support HR 3978 to amend the definition
of a production facility to clarify the
spent fuel processing facilities may be
licensed under the same regulatory
process as other fuel cycle facilities
rather than a production facility. My
home state of Idaho is home to the Idaho
National Lab, the premier nuclear
research facility in the country. In
July, Department of Energy announced
that Idaho is one of five states,
including Tennessee, Utah, Oklahoma, and
Louisiana as potential host states for
the nuclear life cycle innovation
campus, a new effort to strengthen and
modernize the nation's full nuclear fuel
cycle. It's expected that the campus
will attract significant investment,
expand domestic manufacturing, and
create thousands of new high-paying
jobs. The United States is seeing a
resurgence in nuclear energy, and Idaho
is leading the way. With that, I support
HR 3978 to yield back.
>> Thank you. The gentleman yields back.
Are there any other members wishing to
speak on the bill? The gentleman from
Florida is recognized for five minutes.
Speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, chairman. Energy prices are
rising, especially because of tariffs,
the the war, and and more. And so, it's
more important than ever that we're
modernizing our energy mix in Florida
and across the nation and making it
cleaner and more affordable. Natural
gas, nuclear, and solar provide the
foundation powering the Sunshine State.
Natural gas doesn't have the coal issues
that we've uh seen with the coal ash in
Central Florida, and solar is expanding
by leaps and bounds. We currently have
two gray hydrogen plants mixing solar,
creating hydrogen, mixing it with
methane. Uh eventually these plants will
go to full green hydrogen in places like
Oyola and Okchobee with the FPNL and
Duke leading the way. And nuclear plants
are a critical part of that mix. uh we
need to continue to make sure they're
safe, that we're advancing the
technology, that we're lowering costs,
and that we are lowering CO2 emissions.
But that progress has stalled.
Since 2000, we've only seen three new
nuclear units constructed in our
country. Today, we have a slate of
bipartisan bills to modernize our
nuclear policy. These bills will
modernize reprocessing of spent fuel
rods, streamline construction,
regulation, and public hearings,
restructure of the nuclear advisory
committee, increase NRC's salaries, and
improve transparency. All these reforms
will improve and speed up the
construction of uh nuclear power plants
that we make sure maintain critical
safety standards, increase our lower
emissions, lower energy costs, and uh
help modernize um the energy system both
in Florida and across the nation. With
that, I yield back.
>> Thank you. The gentleman yields back.
The chair now recognizes the gentleman
from Colorado's 8th district for five
minutes to speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Mr. Chairman, and thank
you to my good friend uh Mr. Peters uh
for your work on this bipartisan common
sense piece of legislation. Uh I'm a
proud co-sponsor of the Nuclear Refuel
Act and one of the other nuclear bills
that we're hearing today. Um and I urge
my colleagues to join me in supporting
these bills. And I do want to clarify
something that I just heard though. Uh,
energy prices are rising, at least in
Colorado, because state Democrats, who
happen to be located in the capital city
of Denver, are mandating a $61 billion
transition toward less affordable energy
sources. And that's their own 2025 study
that shows that their energy policies
are costing Coloradoatans 61 billion
more dollars. While that's happening,
this administration and congressional
Republicans are focused on and
prioritizing practable uh practical
affordable policies that strengthen
American energy leadership and lower
costs. As I continue uh focusing on an
all of the- above uh energy strategy,
nuclear energy must remain an essential
part of that platform. The United States
must establish a full nuclear fuel cycle
to meet emerging energy demand with
reliable energy sources and strengthen
our energy security. My district is home
to the last operating nuclear power
plant in Colorado. It was decommissioned
in the 1980s. And while it now serves my
community as a natural gas generating uh
electrical generating plant, uh Fort St.
Brain still stores over 33,000 lbs of
spent nuclear fuel. Witnesses who have
testified in front of this committee
previously have confirmed that the
Nuclear Refuel Act will spur innovation
in recycled and used nuclear fuel and
that helps us pursue domestic
opportunities for development. This is
good policy not only because it helps us
secure a reliable energy system. It
helps rateayers who are looking for
energy solutions that are lowcost and
effective, but also because it allows us
to put spent fuel to good use instead of
just leaving it right now where it is in
our communities. I've been lucky to work
across the aisle with my good friend Mr.
Peters and others on permitting reform
efforts since the beginning of this
Congress. These nuclear reforms reflect
ideas that have been endorsed by almost
50 bipartisan members of the House who
are engaged in common sense
problem-solving permitting reform
efforts. I'm grateful to my colleagues
on both sides of the aisle for
championing this bill and look forward
to supporting it as it moves through
committee and goes to the House floor. I
urge my colleagues to join me in
supporting the Nuclear Refuel Act and
yield back.
>> Thank you. The gentleman yields back. Is
there any further discussion on the
bill?
Are there any amendments to the bill?
If there are no further If there are no
further discussion, the question now
occurs on HR 3978
and a roll call has been requested. The
clerk will call the role.
>> Mr. Lau,
>> I.
>> Mr. Lada votes I. Mr. Griffith,
Mr. Biller Rockus,
Mr. Hudson,
Mr. Carter of Georgia,
Mr. Palmer,
Mr. Dunn,
Mr. Krenshaw, Mr. Joyce, Mr. Joyce votes
I. Mr. Weber, Mr. Allen,
Mr. Allen votes I. Mr. Balderson, Mr.
Balderson votes I. Mr. Fulture. Mr.
Fulture votes I. Mr. Fluger. Mrs.
Harshburgger. Mrs. Harshburgger votes I.
Mrs. Miller Meeks. Mrs. Kamik.
Mr. Obernolulti.
Mr. James. Mr. Bence. Mr. Bence votes I.
Mrs. Hchin. Mrs. Hchin votes I. Mr. Fry.
Mr. Fry votes I. Miss. Lee.
Mr. Langworthy. Mr. Mr. Langworthy votes
I. Mr. Kain Mr. Kane votes I. Mr.
Roelly.
>> Mr. Roelly votes I. Mr. Evans.
>> Mr. Evans votes I. Mr. Goldman. Mr.
Goldman votes I. Mrs. Fedorch.
>> Mrs. Fedorch votes I. Mr. Palone. Mr.
Palone votes I. Miss Dette. Miss Dette
votes I. Miss. Shakowski.
Miss. Mattsuie. Miss. Matsuie votes I.
Miss Caster. Miss Caster votes I. Mr.
Mr. Tonko,
Miss Clark,
Mr. Ruiz,
Mr. Peters, Mr. Peters votes I. Mrs.
Dingle, Mrs. Jingle votes I. Mr. Vzy,
Mr. Vzy votes I. Miss Kelly,
Miss Kelly votes I. Miss Baron,
Mr. Sodto.
>> Mr. Stoodto votes I. Miss Shrier. Miss
Shrier votes I. Miss Trean. Miss Trean
votes I. Miss. Fletcher. Miss Fletcher
votes I. Miss Aassio Cortez. Miss
Aassiocortez votes I. Mr. Aenclaus. Mr.
Aenclaus votes I. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana. Mr. Carter of Louisiana vids
I. Mr. Menendez. Mr. Menendez vids I.
Mr. Mullen.
Mr. Lansman Mr. Lansman votes I. Miss
McClen Miss McClen votes I. Mr. Guthrie
>> Mr. Guthrie votes I
>> see the gentleman from North Carolina
recorded.
>> Mr. Hudson votes I.
>> Gentleman from Florida.
>> Bill votes I.
>> Mr. Bill Rockus votes I.
>> Gentleman from Virginia
>> votes I.
>> Mr. Griffith votes I.
>> Gentleman from Georgia.
>> I.
>> Mr. Carter of Georgia votes I. Gentleman
from Alabama,
>> M.
>> Mr. Palmer votes I.
>> Uh, the gentle lady from Illinois.
>> Miss Shakowski is not recorded.
>> Gentleman from New York.
>> Yes.
>> Miss Shakowski votes I.
>> The gentleman from New York.
>> Gentlemen,
>> Mr. Tonka is not recorded.
>> Mr. Tonka votes I. The gentleman from
California,
>> Miss Baragon is not recorded.
>> I'm sorry. The gentleman.
>> Oh,
>> sorry.
>> Sorry, Mr. Ruiz votes.
>> And the gentle lady from California,
>> uh, Miss Baron votes.
>> The gentle lady from New York.
>> The Miss Clark is not recorded.
>> Miss Clark votes I.
>> Are there any other members wishing to
record their vote?
hearing. None. The clerk will report.
Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 44
eyes and zero nos.
>> Thank you very much. The eyes have it
and the bill is adopted.
The chair calls up HR 9612 and ask the
clerk to report
>> HR 9612, a bill to amend the atomic.
Without objection, the first reading of
the bill is dispensed with and the bill
will be open for amendment at any point
so ordered.
Does anyone seek to be recognized on the
bill?
Are there any amendments on the bill?
>> Mr. Chairman, I have an amendment for
purposes. The gentleman from South
Carolina wish to be recognized.
>> Mr. Chairman, I have an amendment in the
nature of the substitute on the desk.
The U clerk will uh report
the
>> amendment in the nature of a substitute
to HR 9612 offered by Mr. Fry. Strike
all options.
>> Without objection, the reading of the
amendment is dispensed with and the
gentleman is recognized for five minutes
in support of the amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. The goal of HR
9612, which I introduced along with Miss
Shrier and Miss Houchin, is to amend the
Atomic Energy Act so that the license
licensing for these facilities align
with the more efficient framework for
other nuclear fuel uh cycle facilities,
namely the uranium conversion and fuel
fabrication. The bill makes clear, for
example, that construction of enrichment
facilities would be allowed prior to
licensing under the same terms and
conditions already applicable to these
other types of fuel cycle facilities.
Testimony from industry experts
indicated that these provisions could
shave off over a year from the licensing
process. There would be no impact on
safety assessments or inspections, no
impact on environmental assessments
required under NEPA, nor any of the
requirements or safeguards and security
to meet the relevant provisions of the
atomic energy act. It will not affect
the ability of people affected by
license by the licensing from requesting
a hearing. Uh this ains which reflects
bipartisan agreement simply perfects the
bill to ensure that it more fully aligns
with congressional intent. It removes an
excess provision related relating to
inspections made unnecessary by core
amendments to the bill. This helps
ensure that the licensing framework
matches that of other fuel facilities.
It moves clarifying NRC authorities to
another section of the bill and it adds
explicit language that NEPA requirements
will not be affected uh and that the
authority of the NRC to conduct
inspections of enrichment facilities
will also not be affected. If we're
going to build out our nuclear industry,
we need nuclear fuel for that industry.
We need to secure abundant supply of
that fuel made domestically. In my state
of South Carolina, for example, where
nuclear power makes up 59% of our
electricity, we're planning a major
expansion to meet our power demands for
industry and our residents. American
enrichment expansion is essential for
that nuclear buildout. And this bill
helps it make it make it more efficient
path to safe and secure and more
abundant enrichment in the United
States. I urge uh support of the Ames
and for HR 9612 broadly. With that, Mr.
Chairman, I yield back.
>> Thank you very much. Is are there any
other members? The gentle lady from
Washington's 8th district is recognized
for five minutes.
>> Thank you, Mr. chairman and and thank
you uh to representatives Fry and
Houchin for their partnership on this.
Uh as we work to expand our nation's
buildout of nuclear power, we need a
steep rapid increase in our domestic
production of nuclear fuel. And right
now, um we don't have enough enrichment
capacity. One thing standing in our way
is how we regulate enrichment facilities
during the licensing process. Um and
unlike applicants of most standard fuel
cycle facilities, enri uranium
enrichment facility applicants can't
begin construction of the facility prior
to licensing. This is referred to as at
risk construction because there is a
risk that the license will be denied.
But many applicants are willing to take
that risk. Uh the licensing process can
take years and any delays in licensing
or construction just leave us further
behind in building our own enrichment
capacity and bringing nuclear energy to
market. So building while going through
the licensing process saves time without
compromising any safety. Adversaries
like Russia have far surpassed us and
own nearly half of the world's uranium
enrichment capabilities. And meanwhile,
the US has just one operating enrichment
plant. And with the ban on Russian
uranium inputs that this committee very
appropriately enacted, we need our own
nuclear fuel supply chain. It's a
national security issue. So that's why
I'm so proud to lead the American
Enrichment Deployment Act with
Congressman Fry, Congresswoman Hachin to
streamline uh the licensing process for
the enrichment facilities while
preserving NRC's safety mission. Uh this
would give applicants of uranium
enrichment facilities the exact same
option to start at risk construction
that applicants of other fuel cycle
facilities can utilize. Um I want to
thank Chairman Guthrie and uh Chairman
Lada's staff along with Representative
Fry uh for offering this amendment to
clarify some portions of the legislative
text of this bill. The amendment makes
clear that existing permitting rules
still apply to enrichment facilities.
Um, we were never far apart on the
intent. Uh, but this amendment just
helps make things crystal clear and
makes the bill even stronger. So, for
the sake of our energy independence and
national security and an imminent need
to fuel advanced reactors and reduce
greenhouse gas emissions, I urge this
committee to vote yes on this amendment
and on the bill and I yield back. Thank
you.
>> Well, thank you very much. The gentle
yields back. Are there other members?
The for what purpose does the gentle
lady from Indiana seek recognition?
>> I wish to speak on the amendment.
>> The gentle lady's recognized for five
minutes. Speak on the amendment.
>> Thank you uh chairman Lada. I also want
to thank uh representatives Fry and
Shrier for their partnership on this uh
very important uh bill which will
modernize outdated licensing quirks that
treat uranium enrichment facilities
different from every other link in the
uranium uh nuclear fuel chain costing
years and hundreds of millions of
dollars without adding a shred of
additional safety. It removes a
bottleneck, not a safeguard, and it's a
key part to standardizing America's
approach to nuclear. It allows for
faster construction and deployment of
our nuclear facilities with again no
risk to safety. Sourcing abundant fuel
will be a key component to unlocking
America's nuclear renaissance and
delivering emissionsfree power that the
growing economy needs.
Again, this bill is developing a
framework that is essential for energy
providers to increase and develop our
domestic dis supply, including companies
like Fanco based in Indiana.
It makes common sense that we would
allow for certain construction uh to go
ahead and continue uh through the
process eliminating potentially years of
delays which um nuclear in our port
portfolio especially uh small modular
nuclear reactors uh should be part of
the energy conversation for the United
States. I'm very pleased to be uh
helping on this effort. Again, my thanks
to uh Representative Fry for his
leadership and uh Miss Shrier for uh
partnership on this very important bill.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I yield back.
>> Thank you. Are there any other members
wishing to be recognized to speak on the
Ames?
Hearing none, a vote will occur on the
AS. All those in favor will signify
signify by saying I. I. All those
opposed? Nay. The eyes have it and the
Ames is agreed to. Are there any further
amendments to the bill?
Hearing none, the question now occurs on
adopting the
HR 9612 as amended. A roll call vote has
been requested and the clerk will call
the role.
>> Mr. Lada.
>> I.
>> Mr. Lada votes I. Mr. Griffith. Mr.
Griffith votes I. Mr. Mr. Bill Rockus.
Mr. Bill Rockus votes I. Mr. Hudson,
Mr. Carter of Georgia.
Mr. Palmer,
Mr. Dunn,
Mr. Krenshaw,
Mr. Joyce, Mr. Joyce votes I. Mr. Weber,
Mr. Allen,
Mr. Allen votes I. Mr. Balderson, Mr.
Balderson votes I. Mr. Fulture. Mr.
Fulture votes I. Mr. Fluger.
Mrs. Harshburgger.
Mrs. Harshburgger votes I. Mrs. Miller
Meeks. Mrs. Kamik.
Mr. Obernolulti.
Mr. James.
Mr. Bence. Mr. Bence votes I. Mrs.
Houchin. Mrs. Hchin votes I. Mr. Fry.
>> Mr. Fry votes I. Miss.
Mr. Langworthy.
>> Mr. Langworthy votes I. Mr. Kaine Mr.
Kane votes I. Mr. Roelly.
>> Mr. Roelly votes I. Mr. Evans.
>> Mr. Evans votes I. Mr. Goldman. Mr.
Goldman votes I. Mrs. Fedorch.
>> Mrs. Fedorch votes I. Mr. Palone.
>> I.
>> Mr. Palone votes I. Miss Dette.
>> Mr. Dette votes I. Miss Shakowski.
>> I.
>> Miss Shakowski votes I. Miss Matsui
>> Miss Matsui votes I. Miss Caster. Miss
Caster votes I. Mr. Tonka
>> I.
>> Mr. Tonka votes I. Miss. Clark. Miss.
Clark votes I. Mr. Ruiz.
Mr. Peters. Mr. Peters votes I.
Mr. Ruiz votes I. Mrs. Dingle. Mrs.
Dingle votes I. Mr. Vy. Mr. Vy votes I.
Miss. Kelly. Miss. Kelly votes I. Miss
Baron Miss Baron votes I. Mr. Sodto Mr.
Sodto votes I. Miss Shrier Miss Shrier
votes I. Miss Trean M. Trean votes I.
Miss Fletcher.
Miss Fletcher votes I. Miss
Aassiocortez.
Miss Aassiocortez votes I. Mr. Aenclaus.
Mr. Aenclaus votes I. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana. Mr. Carter of Louisiana votes
I. Mr. Menendez. Mr. Menendez votes I.
Mr. Mullen
Mr. Lansman Mr. Lansman votes I. Miss
Mlullen Miss McClen votes I. Mr.
Guthrie.
>> Mr. Guthrie votes I.
>> Mr. Palmer
>> Mr. Palmer is not recorded.
>> Mr. Carter
I.
>> Mr. Carter of Georgia votes I.
>> Anyone seeking to answer the roll call?
Seeing none. The clerk will report.
Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 43
eyes and zero nos.
>> The eyes have it and the bill is
adopted. The chair calls up HR5549 and
asks the clerk to report.
>> HR5549,
a bill to amend the Atomic Energy Act of
1954 to provide for more efficient
hearings on nuclear facility
construction applications and for other
purposes.
>> Without objection, the first reading of
the bill is dispensed with and the bill
will be open for amendment at any point.
So order. Does anyone seek recognition
to be recognized on the bill? For what
purpose does the gentleman from Virginia
seek recognition to strike the last
word?
>> No, but speak on.
>> I know that's procedurally wrong, right?
I just wanted to point that out. All
right. The gentleman is recognized.
>> Mr. Chairman, thank you for letting me
speak on my bill, HR5549,
the Efficient Nuclear Licensing Hearing
Act. I am proud to see this bipartisan
bill that I introduced along with
Congresswoman Shrier and Congressman Vzy
be included on today's full committee
markup. HR5549 would amend the Atomic
Energy Act to repeal the requirements
for a public nuclear reactor license
hearing even when no one in the public
or an affected party requests such
hearing. In most cases, these mandatory
hearings for operating licenses only
occur because they are required by law,
not because they are essential for factf
finding exercises or for fact or or for
factf finding exercises of the nuclear
regulatory commission. These really are
the hearings that nobody asks for.
Mandatory hearings are relics from the
1950s when nuclear licensing processes
were first being structured and every
reactor design was a novel one. Today
the need for uncontested hear for the
uncontested hearing is simply a waste of
resources. We had a hearing earlier this
year where um the recollection that I
have is that one of the witnesses said
that a nuclear license applicant pays a
fee of over $300 per hour for NRC staff
to prepare for the hearing. And one of
the witnesses said there could be up to
12 NRC staff at each hearing. You can
see how that can add up pretty quickly
on the cost for an applicant. Multiple
current and former former NRC
commissioners of both parties have
agreed the mandatory hearings are not
necessary. Removing this mandatory
hearing would in no way affect public
scoping and citing meetings. Repealing
mandatory hearings would also not affect
the right of any affected party to
request a hearing on specific matters.
The bill also codifies current NRC
practices that use informal
non-adversarial hearing procedures. Over
the past two congresses, this committee
has received testimony showing that
repealing this hearing requirement would
not jeopardize public safety. I thank
Congresswoman Shrier and Congressman Vzy
for helping lead this bill with me and I
urge all of my colleagues to vote in
favor of reporting it to the floor.
Thank you so much and I yield back.
>> Gentlemen yields back. The gentle lady
from Washington was recognized for five
minutes to speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I I'm proud to
lead the efficient nuclear licensing
hearing act with Congressman Griffith
and Congressman VC to reduce some of the
administrative burdens that just slow
licensing of nuclear reactors. As I
noted earlier, we need to increase the
pace of our roll out of nuclear energy
without compromising safety. Right now,
nuclear regulators are required to hold
a hearing on both contested and totally
uncontested nuclear reactor projects.
Thousands of staff hours and associated
costs are dedicated to these totally
unnecessary hearings uh for uncontested
projects. These hearings are just
delaying operations. I mean, this is the
very definition of red tape. And this
time could be so much better spent on
critical environmental review or on
reviewing actually contested projects.
Our bill solves this issue by only
requiring a hearing when the issue is
contested so that our regulators are
most effectively serving their mission
to protect public health and safety. And
critically, the bill does not alter in
any way the right of someone to request
a contested hearing. This pragmatic move
uh and balance shifts our regulator's
focus toward the issues that matter and
less on an outdated, unnecessary and
procedural process. Uh this bipartisan
bill cuts red tape, lowers energy costs,
and brings clean energy onto the grid
faster. I urge this committee to vote
yes on this bill, and I yield back.
>> Gentle lady yields back. Is there
further discussion? Gentleman from New
Jersey is recognized for five minutes to
speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I'd like to
speak on the bill. Uh, Mr. Chairman, I
am in support of the Efficient Nuclear
Licensing Hearings Act, of which I am a
co-sponsor. I thank my colleagues,
Representatives Griffith and Shrier, for
leading it. This legislation represents
an opportunity to modernize
outdated and burdenome government
regulation by allowing the NRC to
operate within the reality of current
regulatory needs, not decades old
regulation. This bipartisan bill will
allow us to get more clean, safe power
on the grid quicker and at a lower cost
while still including opportunities for
public engagement and expert review.
I support common sense steps to get more
power on the grid safely and as soon as
possible to lower costs, to improve
stability, and to increase reliability
for New Jersey families. I stand ready
to continue to support good government
regulatory approaches like this bill
that will reduce costs, strengthen the
grid, and improve service for all
Americans. I again thank my colleague
for leading this effort, and I urge
support of the bill. Thank you, and I
yield back.
>> The gentleman yields back. The gentleman
from Texas is recognized for five
minutes. And I before you go, I'll just
for the voice for the whole committee, I
know your your dear wife lost her mother
right before we adjourned. And so all in
our thoughts and prayers
and the gentleman's recognized for five
minutes.
>> Uh Mr. Chairman, thank you very much. I
I really appreciate that and and so will
my wife. Um I was very proud to work
with Mr. Griffith and uh Dr. Shy on this
efficient nuclear license inherent act.
I believe that this is a great
bipartisan bill that is going to cut red
tape that's already been said and bring
more efficiency. I really do believe
that when you start talking about
nuclear power, it is going to be one of
the keys that are going to be necessary
to help us to meet a lot of the rising
energy demands that we're going to have
uh along with cutting carbon emissions,
which I know is very u uh important. Um
I know that there's no perfect form of
of energy. I that's why I don't like to
use the term clean energy. I always like
to use the term cleaner energy. Uh and I
believe that nuclear power can bring
cleaner energy. This is going to cut
delays in the NRC's licensing of new
nuclear power plants without sacrificing
safety or public input. And this also
wouldn't save taxpayers millions of
dollars by speeding up approvals and
helping bring down energy costs for
families in my state of Texas and across
the country. Uh this bill is about good
governance and right now the NRC is
required to hold a hearing before it can
issue a license for a new reactor even
when no one has raised an objection. uh
that this bill simply removes that
automatic requirement and it does not
touch the right of anyone affected uh by
a proposed reactor to request a hearing.
That right stays fully intact and what
changes is a default instead of every
license triggering a hearing whether or
not there's a dispute.
Hearings happen when someone actually
requests one. uh that distinction is
going to be very important because these
mandatory hearings take real time and
real resources and we have a lot of
energy that we have to get up. Uh I
think uh if you look at where nuclear
energy is now versus versus where it was
when I was elected in 2012, we made just
giant leaps forward with it being
embraced more. And we have all these
controversies around data centers now,
which is also going to be a energy
issue. And we have a lot on our plate
energy-wise that we're going to have to
solve for this country. And nuclear
energy can be a big part of us being
able to do that. And again, I want to
thank uh Representatives Griffins and SH
for their work on this. And I yield back
my time. Thank you.
>> Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion?
Seeing none, are there any amendments
for the bill?
Seeing none, and no further discussion,
the question now occurs on adopting
5549. A roll call has been elected or
elected requested and the clerk will
call the role.
Mr. Lau Mr. Lada votes I. Mr. Griffith
Mr. Griffith votes I. Mr. Bill Rockus
Mr. Billacus votes I. Mr. Hudson
Mr. Carter of Georgia Mr. Carter of
Georgia votes I. Mr. Palmer.
Mr. Palmer votes I. Mr. Dunn.
Mr. Crrenshaw.
Mr. Joyce. Mr. Joyce votes I. Mr. Mr.
Weber, Mr. Allen, Mr. Allen votes I. Mr.
Balderson, Mr. Balderson votes I. Mr.
Fulture, Mr. Fulture votes I. Mr.
Fluger, Mrs. Harshburgger, Mrs.
Harshburgger votes I. Mrs. Miller Meeks,
Mrs. Kamik,
Mr. Obernoli,
Mr. James,
Mr. Bence,
Mr. Bence votes I, Mrs. Mrs. Hchin. Mrs.
Mrs. Hchen votes I. Mr. Fry, Miss Lee,
Mr. Langworthy. Mr. Langworthy votes I.
Mr. Kane. Mr. Kane votes I. Mr. Roelly.
Mr. Roelly votes I. Mr. Evans. Mr. Evans
votes I. Mr. Goldman. Mr. Goldman votes
I. Mrs. Fedorch. Mrs. Fedorch votes I.
Mr. Palone.
>> Mr. Palone votes I. M. Dette.
>> I.
>> Mr. Dette votes I. Miss Shakowski.
>> Miss Shakowski votes I. Miss Matsui,
>> I.
>> Miss Matsui votes I. Miss Caster,
>> Miss Caster votes I. Mr. Tonko,
>> I.
>> Mr. Tonko votes I. Miss. Clark.
>> Miss. Clark votes I. Mr. Ruiz. Mr. Ruiz
votes I. Mr. Peters. Mr. Peters votes I.
Mrs. Dingle. Mrs. Mrs. Dingle votes I.
Mr. VC. Mr. VC votes I. Miss. Kelly.
Miss. Kelly votes I. Miss. Baron.
Mr. Sodto. Mr. Sodto votes I. Miss.
Shrier. Miss Shrier votes I. Miss
Treyan. Miss Treyan votes I. Miss
Fletcher.
>> Miss Fletcher votes I. Miss
Aassiocortez.
Miss Aassiocortez votes I. Mr.
Aenclauss.
Mr. Carter of Louisiana. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana votes I. Mr. Mendez. Mr.
Menendez votes I. Mr. Mullen.
>> Mr. Mullen votes I. Mr. Lansman. Mr. Mr.
Lansman votes I. Miss Mcclullen.
>> Miss Mlullen votes I. Mr. Guthrie
>> I.
>> Mr. Guthrie votes I.
>> Are there anyone seeking to roll call?
Mr. Hudson.
>> I.
>> Mr. Hudson votes I.
>> Mr. Aenclaus.
>> Mr. Aenclaus is not recorded.
>> Mr. Aenclaus votes I.
>> Miss Bagon.
>> Miss Baragon is not recorded. Miss
Baragon votes I.
>> Is anyone else seeking to answer the
role? Seeing none, the clerk will
report.
Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 44
eyes and zero na nos.
>> The eyes have it and the bill is
adopted. The chair calls up HR 9613 and
ask the clerk to report. HR 9613,
a bill to update the role of the
advisory committee on reactor safeguards
and the licensing and oversight of
nuclear reactor facilities and for other
purposes.
>> Without objection, the first reading of
the bill is dispensed with and the bill
will be open for amendment at any point.
So order. Does anyone seek to be
recognized on the bill?
>> Anyone the gentle lady from Florida? I
>> have an amendment at the desk.
>> Gentle lady from Florida has a member at
the desk. Would you identify the
amendment? It's ANS-HR9613-01.
>> The clerk will report.
>> Amendment in the nature of a of a
substitute to HR 9613 offered by Miss
Caster.
>> Without objection, the reading of the
amendment is dispensed with and the
gentle lady from Florida is recognized
for five minutes in support of her
amendment.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Back in July
during the energy subcommittee's markup
on uh this bill, I indicated that I had
some concerns with it and suggested a
path forward. And I'd like to thank you,
Mr. Chairman, and your team for
negotiating on an amendment that
addressed uh my issues while keeping the
bill's main uh push for efficiency. I
think this compromise gets us more a
more efficient nuclear licensing process
without sacrificing transparency or
safety. So, it's a win-win. This bill is
about the advisory committee on reactor
safeguards or ACARS. For over 70 years,
this committee has provided valuable
technical expertise to the atomic atomic
energy commission and its successor the
nuclear regulatory commission. Uh they
advise on the safety of nuclear
reactors. In the coming years, NRC will
hopefully be dealing with a wave of new
innovative advanced reactor designs and
the acres will be more important than
ever. Um, right now the law states that
the acres has has to review every single
nuclear rea reactor application for
wellestablished reactor designs that
have been built a dozen times over. I
don't think that makes a lot of sense.
But the the review is vital for new
reactor designs or license applications
that bring other unique, novel or
noteworthy designs. So the acres and the
NRC have already started working
together to ensure that the committee's
focus is on the highest value areas.
This bill codifies that. But
importantly, the amendment would let the
committee uh the nuclear experts
themselves and not the politically
appointed NRC determine which areas
deserve their attention. This is
critical to giving reviews of advanced
nuclear reactors a thorough,
independent, and technical review. Uh
this amendment also restores the
committee's ability to look at safety
issues present in a nuclear power plant
uh but beyond the reactor core ensuring
that the American people can have
confidence in the safety of the entirety
of the nuclear reactor. Overall this
compromise will let the technical
experts focus entirely on the highest uh
the issues of highest importance issues
that are new and that have safety
implications. It lets the commit the
experts do their work instead instead of
silencing them. So I think it's a win
for safe uh and clean nuclear energy.
Again, I want to thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and Representative
Harshburgger for working to find a
bipartisan path forward. I urge all
members of the committee to support the
amendment and to vote yes on final
passage of the underlying bill. Thank
you.
>> Thank you. The gentle lady yields back.
Is there further discussion of the
amendment? Gentle lady from Tennessee is
recognized for five minutes to speak on
the amendment.
>> Okay. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Um, I
want to speak in support of the Ames.
Uh, we had a thoughtful discussion about
the ACRS at the subcommittee markup this
past July. As Representative Caster
said, ranking member Palone and
Representatives Caster and Okaziocortez
raised concerns about the risk that the
legislation might uh unnecessarily limit
ACRS's ability to advise on important
safety matters. and I committed at that
point to work to address the concerns
and the ACRS is an important independent
advisor to the NRC for uh reactor
licensing and it's had a long history of
assisting nuclear regulatory commission
decisions on unique and important safety
and technical issues. Congress
established the ACRS in law in the 1950s
to assist the commission on safety
significant issues when it was licensing
the first generation of nuclear
reactors. Those reactors and
technologies are now well characterized
and understood. And we heard in
testimony during the legislative hearing
that the NRC technical staff is well
equipped to deal with licensing issues
with the record of some 4,500 years of
operational experience of the existing
fleet to draw from. However, a new wave
of technologies on the horizon and
certain specific circumstances would
very much still benefit from ACRS
independent review and advice. And the
goal of HR 9613 is to focus ACRS work on
where it will provide the greatest value
for the NRC and the public. The bill
amends the Atomic Energy Act to direct
that ACRS focus on issues that are
directly related to reactor design or
safety significant and are novel and
have not been previously acted upon by
the committee. And this a reflects
constructive input by the minority staff
to maintain this focus while addressing
the minority's concerns. The a drops uh
the provisions that require ACRS to act
on application reviews only when the
commission directs it to act. It also
provides ACS the flexibility to choose
not to do a review if it decides the
review is unnecessary if the application
doesn't raise issues that warrant
review. ACRS controls the decision and
this is a good compromise. In the end,
this bill helps align the mission of the
ACRS with the mission of the NRC as we
outlined in the advance act and the AIS
uh effectively puts ACRS in the driver's
seat for what to review and does so in a
way that will make its work for the NRC
and the public more efficient and
useful. This reflects collaborative
bipartisan work and should be widely
supported. So, thank you, Mr. Chairman.
With that, I yield back.
>> Gentle lady yields back. Is there
further discussion of the amendment?
>> Gentleman from Texas is recognized to
speak on the amendment.
>> Thank you very much, Mr. Chairman. Texas
in the middle of the biggest energy
buildout in the country. Our grid
operator is projecting demand growth
that will require every resource we can
bring online, including next generation
nuclear. This bill and amendment
eliminates bureaucratic duplication in
the nuclear permitting process, allowing
novel and safety significant reviews to
move forward in a more efficient manner.
I'd like to thank my friend from
Tennessee and for her leadership on this
critical reform. I also like to thank
Miss Caster and the colleagues across
the aisle for working to advance this
legislation. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I
yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discuss discussion of the amendment?
Seeing none, the question occurs on the
amendment. All those in favor shall say
I.
>> I.
>> All those opposed, nay. The eyes have it
and the amendment is agreed to. Are
there further amendments?
Seeing none, the question now occurs on
adopting HR 9613 as amended. A roll call
has been requested and the clerk will
call the role.
>> Mr. Lada. Mr. Mr. Lada votes I. Mr.
Griffith. Mr. Griffith votes I. Mr. Bill
Rockus. Mr. Bill Rockus votes I. Mr.
Hudson.
Mr. Carter of Georgia. Mr. Carter of
Georgia votes I. Mr. Palmer.
Mr. Palmer votes I. Mr. Dunn. Mr.
Krenshaw. Mr. Joyce. Mr. Joyce votes I.
Mr. Weber. Mr. Allen.
Mr. Allen votes I. Mr. Balderson. Mr.
Balderson votes I. Mr. Fulture Mr.
Fulture votes I. Mr. Fluger Mrs.
Harshburgger Mrs. Harshburgger votes I.
Mrs. Miller Meeks
Mrs. Kamik
Mr. Obernolulti
Mr. James
Mr. Bent Mr. Bence votes I. Mrs. Hchen
Mrs. Hchen votes I. Mr. Fry
Miss Lee
Mr. Mr. Langworthy. Mr. Langworthy votes
I. Mr. Kain Mr. Kane votes I. Mr. Roelly
Mr. Roelly votes I. Mr. Evans.
>> Mr. Evans votes I. Mr. Goldman.
Mr. Goldman votes I. Mrs. Fedorch. Mrs.
Fedorch votes I. Mr. Palone.
>> Mr. Palone votes I. Miss Dette.
>> Hi.
>> Mr. Dette votes I. Miss Shakowski.
>> Miss Shakowski votes I. Miss Matsui.
>> Miss Matsui votes I. Miss Caster. Miss
Caster votes I. Mr. Tonko
>> I.
>> Mr. Tonka votes I. Miss. Clark. Mr.
Ruiz. Mr. Ruiz votes I. Mr. Peters. Mr.
Peters votes I. Mrs. Dingle. Mrs. Dingle
votes I. Mr. VC. Mr. VC votes I. Miss.
Kelly. Miss. Kelly votes
I.................... Miss. Baron. Miss.
Baragon. Votes I. Mr. Sodto. Mr. Sodto
votes I. Miss Shrier. Miss Shrier votes
I. Miss Trean. Miss. Treyan votes I.
Miss Fletcher. Miss Fletcher votes I.
Miss Aassio Cortez.
Mr. Aenclaus. Mr. Aenclaus votes I. Mr.
Carter of Louisiana. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana votes I. Mr. Mendez. Mr.
Menendez votes I. Mr. Mullen.
Mr. Mullen votes I. Mr. Lansman. Mr.
Lansman votes I. Miss. Mlen. Miss. Mlen
votes I. Mr. Guthrie. Mr. Guthrie votes
I.
>> Anyone seeking recognition to answer the
roll call? Seeing none, the clerk will
report.
Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 41
eyes and zero nos.
>> The eyes have it and the bill is agre
adopted. The chair calls up HR9614 and
asks the clerk to report.
>> HR 9614,
a bill to amend the Atomic Energy Act of
1954 to provide compensation authority
for certain career appointees and for
other purposes.
>> Without objection, the first reading of
the bill is dispensed with and the bill
would be open for amendment at any
point. So ordered. Does anyone seek to
be recognized on the bill? Gentleman
from Georgia see you're recognized for
five minutes to speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, Mr. Mr. Chairman, Mr.
Chairman, I'd like to speak in support
of HR 9614,
the NRC Staff Pay Alignment Act. The
level of expertise demanded by positions
at the NRC require highly qualified
candidates. Candidates which are also
desirable for the private sector,
creating retention pressures to help
usher in the nuclear renaissance and the
deployment of advanced reactors. The NRC
will need to attract and maintain a
robust, specialized workforce. This is
why the committee granted the NRC
special workforce authorities in the
advance act to ensure the commission has
the proper staff to conduct safety and
oversight and to provide an efficient
and predictable licensing framework to
get more reactors built at lower and
lower energy cost. HR 9614 the NRC staff
pay alignment act makes a technical fix
to the workforce authorities we granted
the NRC in the advance act. The
correction ensures that the special
workforce authorities are provided the
career senior executive service
positions at the NRC who play a vital
role in fulfilling NRC's mission. This
technical fix to the advance act will
help the NRC maintain a strong
specialized workforce as well as the
quality management necessary to carry
out NRC's mission. I urge my colleagues
to support this bill and I yield the
balance of my time.
>> Gentleman yields back. The gentleman
from New Jersey is recognized for five
minutes to speak on the bill.
>> Thank you, Chairman. I'm grateful that
the committee is continuing to advance
my bill HR9614, the NRC staff pay
alignment act. This bill would increase
the pay of senior executive service
positions at the nuclear regulatory
commission to help the commission
recruit and retain experts. I want to
especially thank Congresswoman Deette
who authored advance act provisions that
laid the groundwork for this bill.
Hiring and retaining safety experts at
the NRC is paramount to keeping our
communities safe, especially as nuclear
energy continues to become a central
piece of the conversation about meeting
our rapidly growing energy demands. In
New Jersey, nuclear is a core piece of
the state's plan to address skyrocketing
energy bills. We can all agree that
nuclear reactors have unique safety risk
for our communities. That's why it's so
important that we build trust about the
safety of nuclear facilities. And trust
is built through independent
institutions that are responsible for
ensuring reactors meet the highest
standards of safety imaginable. Those
institutions such as the NRC must be
fully staffed with the top experts in
nuclear safety. This bill helps us do
just that. However, since January 2025,
over 400 career staff have left the NRC
with teams that handle safety
experiencing the most significant staff
reductions. And since January 2025,
there have been several other red flags.
I'd like to take a moment to highlight
just a few of those. Seth Cohen, who was
leading the Doge charge at the NRC, said
the goal was to make the agency a quote
rubber stamp for the Trump
administration and dismissed safety
concerns raised by NRC staff. Career NRC
lawyers working on key cases have left
the NRC. And in April, the Democratic
commissioners testified before the
energy subcommittee. They were concerned
about being fired for not approving a
nuclear reactor that the Trump
administration wants. Incidences like
those erode public trust and confidence
in the NRC, an agency that is
historically independent and trusted to
keep safety as a core pillar of their
work, and generally puts our communities
at risk. But this bill is an important
first step toward rebuilding trust. It
gives the NRC a tool to hire and retain
the best experts in the industry. This
bill can help the federal government
compete with the private industry,
incentivizes top experts to stay at the
commission. I urge my colleagues to
support the bill, and I yield back.
>> Will the gentleman yield?
>> Yes. to me up here. Thank you. Well, I I
just um I want to thank the gentleman
for sponsoring this bill and carrying
the torch further, recognizing that if
we are actually going to try to build
more nuclear reactors, we have to have
um we have to have qualified staff over
at the NRC. And as the gentleman said
last Congress, former energy
subcommittee chairman Jeff Duncan and I
passed the Advance Act to accelerate the
development and licensing of of nuclear
energy. But as the gentleman said, um,
we've had systemic staff under agency
underststaffing all the whole time. And
so that's why it's so important that we
pass this legislation. We need it more
than ever to reach the nation's
ambitious nuclear energy goals. And um
frankly the Trump administration has had
even though the stated goal is to
increase nuclear energy the fact is what
they're doing with the workforce is
really uh hurting us. the NRC was
already facing a shrinking workforce,
which is why we needed the Advance Act.
But um but at the same time, as you
heard, a Democratic commissioner was
fired, offloaded uh authority to the
energy department, and then the White
House said it was going to review all
draft rules. Last year, the NRC lost
over 10% of its workforce, which is more
than 330 staff positions, mostly senior
positions, and onethird of those
departures accepted governmentwide
buyouts from Doge. In the n last 19
months, this agency has lost 510
employees and has only added 59 new
staff. So, if you're trying to license
more reactors more quickly, if safety,
which it needs to, is to remain
paramount, the NRC needs more staff with
the proper expertise to ensure the new
reactors are safe. And that's why we
have to give the NRC more tools, but we
also have to make sure that their
existing tools like their senior staff
are used to the best of their ability.
What we have heard since the advance act
passed is the NRC has underutilized the
tools that we gave them partially out of
fear that the authorities were to be
designed to be a applied to a broad
class of employees. And so so that's not
the case. That was never the case. It
was never intended. They were designed
to give the NRC flexibility even to
specific employees and not just be a
blunt tool. And so I hope that this
legislation will help clarify that. I
hope the NRC can use it to deploy its
tools and I hope we can have meaningful
steps to enable the NRC to address these
staffing shortages. Thank you again uh
Congressman Menendez for doing this
bill. I yield back.
>> Thank you. I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back. Is there further
discussion on the the bill?
Is there amendment? No. Any further
discussion on the bill? Seeing none, the
question now occurs.
Question occurs on adopting HR 9614.
A roll call has been requested and the
clerk will call the role.
>> Mr. Lau Mr. Lada votes I. Mr. Griffith
Mr. Griffith votes I. Mr. Bill Rockus.
Mr. Hudson Mr. Hudson votes I. Mr.
Carter of Georgia. Mr. Carter of Georgia
votes I. Mr. Palmer. Mr. Palmer votes I.
Mr. Dunn. Mr. Krenshaw.
Mr. Joyce. Mr. Joyce votes I. Mr. Weber.
Mr. Allen.
Mr. Allen votes I. Mr. Balderson. Mr.
Balderson votes I. Mr. Fulture. Mr.
Fulcher votes I. Mr. Fluger. Mrs.
Harshburgger. Mrs. Harshburgger votes I.
Mrs. Miller Meeks. Mrs. Miller Meeks
votes I. Mrs. Kamik Mr. Obernalty
Mr. James Mr. Bence Mr. Bence votes I
Mrs. Hchin Mrs. Howchin votes I Mr. Fry
Miss Lee
Mr. Langworthy Mr. Langworthy votes I
Mr. Kain Mr. Kane votes I Mr. Roelly Mr.
Roelly votes I Mr. Evans Mr. Evans votes
I Mr. Goldman Mr. Goldman votes I. Mrs.
Fedorch Mrs. Fedorek votes I. Mr.
Palone. Mr. Palone votes I. Mr. Dette.
>> Mr. Dette votes I. Miss Shakowski
>> vote I.
>> Miss Shakowski votes I. Miss Matsui.
>> I.
>> Miss Matsui votes I. Miss Caster
>> Miss Caster votes I. Miss Mr. Tonko.
>> I.
>> Mr. Tonka votes I. Miss. Clark.
>> Mr. Mr. Ruiz Mr. Ruiz votes I. Mr.
Peters Mr. Peters votes I. Mrs. Dingle
Mr. VC Mr. VC votes I. Miss Kelly Miss
Kelly votes I. Miss Baragon.
Mr. Sodto. Mr. Sodto votes I. Miss
Shrier. Miss Shrier votes I. Miss Trean.
Miss Trean votes I. Miss Fletcher. Miss
Fletcher votes I. Miss Aassiocortez.
Mr. Mr. Aenclaus. Mr. Aenclaus votes I.
Mr. Carter of Louisiana. Mr. Carter of
Louisiana votes I. Mr. Menendez. Mr.
Menendez votes I. Mr. Mullen. Mr. Mullen
votes I. Mr. Lansman. Mr. Lansman votes
I. Miss McClullen. Miss Mlullen votes I.
Mr. Guthrie. Mr. Guthrie votes I.
>> Is anyone seeking to answer the roll
call?
>> Seeing none, the clerk will report.
You Mr. Bill Rockus how's he recorded?
>> Mr. Bill Rockus is not recorded.
>> Mr. Bill Rockus votes I.
>> Lor report.
Before you report as how's Miss Baragon
Miss Baron recorded
>> Miss Baron is not recorded.
>> Miss Baragon votes I.
>> Clerk will report.
Nobody else.
>> Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 42
eyes and zero nos. The eyes have it and
the bill is adopted. The chair calls up
HR9084 and ask the clerk to report.
>> HR9084,
a bill to increase transparency relating
to the Department of Energy's
authorizations of certain nuclear
facilities.
>> Without objection, the first reading of
the bill is dispensed with and the bill
will be open for amendment at any point.
So ordered. Does anyone seek to be
recognized on the bill? For purpose, the
gentle lady from Iowa seek recognition.
Move to strike the last word.
>> Gentle lady gentle lad is recognized to
speak on the bill.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Uh thank you, Mr. Chairman. I'm proud to
co-lead HR 9084, the Department of
Energy Nuclear Transparency Act with
Representative Caster. Our bill would
direct the Department of Energy to
publicly announce information on
decisions related to nuclear licensing
and authorization activities.
Transparency is a vital component of
maintaining the public's trust in our
nuclear regulators and keeping the
public informed on Department of
Energy's nuclear activities helps uphold
this transparency. The Nuclear
Regulatory Commission already diligently
follows public notification and
engagement practices throughout its
nuclear licensing process. This bill
ensures that the DOE maintains similar
standards to keep the public and
Congress well informed on its nuclear
activities. After bipartisan
deliberation and technical input from
the DOE and experts experts, this bill
was refined amend has was refined
amendment to provide more time for the
DOE reporting and strengthen protections
for sensitive information disclosures. I
appreciate my colleagues across the
aisle for their meaningful input to get
this bill right. I urge my colleagues to
support this bill. I yield back.
>> Gentle lady yields back and the gentle
lady from Florida seeks recognition to
speak on the bill. Gentle is recognized
for five minutes to speak on the bill.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Colleagues,
over the past year, the Department of
Energy has renewed efforts to authorize
and stand up advanced nuclear reactors,
test reactors. Uh the DOE test pilot
program is helping reduce perceived risk
and catalyze private investment and
advance US strategic leadership. Done
right, uh this program could help ensure
that this nuclear renaissance actually
takes off. done wrong, it could shatter
public confidence in nuclear energy for
a generation. Uh so while all the
progress is important, it is equally
necessary to provide transparency in the
decision-making processes at DOE. Um on
the previous bill, you heard about how
many hundreds of expert technical staff
at DOE have been um fired or lost. They
had great technical capacity. It's a
little worrisome about what's really
going on at the department as they
proceed with this nuclear renaissance.
Nuclear energy cannot succeed in the
United States without public trust in
the industry. Uh so my bill with my
colleague from Iowa says the department
of energy uh uh has to be transparent.
That's what our nuclear transparency act
is all about. It would introduce
transparency requirements for DOE's
nuclear programs, ensuring that its
safety decisions can withstand public
and industry scrutiny. And I think we
can all agree that congressional
oversight is very important. It's also
important that we distinguish between
DOE's uh authorities and the nuclear
regulatory commission's separate
approval process for new commercial
reactors. If done correctly and with the
right policy support, nuclear energy can
safely power the US economy with clean
and reliable energy. Uh I appreciate all
of us working together to advance this
bill and I urge everyone to support it
and yield back. Thank you.
>> Gentle lady yields back. Is there
further discussion on the bill?
>> Seeing none, are there any amendments to
the bill?
Seeing none,
the question now occurs on adopting
HR9084.
A roll call has been requested and the
clerk will call the role.
>> Mr. Lau Mr. Lau votes I. Mr. Griffith,
Mr. Griffith votes I. Mr. Billis,
Mr. Hudson,
Mr. Hudson votes I. Mr. Carter of
Georgia.
>> Mr. Carter of Georgia votes I. Mr.
Palmer Mr. Palmer votes I. Mr. Dunn
Mr. Krenshaw
Mr. Joyce Mr. Joyce votes I. Mr. Weber
Mr. Allen Mr. Allen votes I. Mr.
Balderson Mr. Balderson votes I. Mr.
Fulture. Mr. Fulcher votes I. Mr.
Fluger.
Mrs. Harshburgger.
Mrs. Harshburgger votes I. Mrs. Miller
Meeks. Mrs. Mrs. Miller Meeks votes I.
Mrs. Kamik,
Mr. Obernalty,
Mr. James, Mr. Bence, Mr. Bence votes I.
Mrs. Hchen, Mrs. Hchen votes I. Mr. Fry,
Miss Lee,
Mr. Langworthy.
>> Mr. Langworthy votes I. Mr. Kaine. Mr.
Kane votes I. Mr. Roelly. Mr. Roelly
votes I. Mr. Evans. Mr. Evans votes I.
Mr. Goldman. Mr. Mr. Goldman votes I.
Mrs. Fedorch Mrs. Fedorch votes I. Mr.
Palone Mr. Palone votes I. Mr. Dette.
>> Miss Shakowski. Miss Shakowski votes I.
Miss Matsui.
>> Miss Matsui votes I. Miss Caster
>> I.
>> Miss Caster votes I. Mr. Tonko.
>> Mr. Tonka votes I. Miss. Clark.
>> Mr. Ruiz. Mr. Ruiz votes I. Mr. Peters.
Mr. Peters votes I. Mrs. Jingle
Mr. VC Mr. BC votes I. Miss Kelly Miss
Kelly votes I. Miss Baron Miss Bargon
votes I. Mr. Sodto Mr. Sodto votes I.
Miss Shrier. Miss Shrier votes I. Miss
Trean. Miss Trean votes I. Miss
Fletcher. Miss Fletcher votes I. Miss
Aassio Cortez.
Mr. Oenclaus. Mr. Aenclaus votes I. Mr.
Carter of Louisiana.
>> Mr. Carter of Louisiana votes I. Mr.
Menendez. Mr. Menendez votes I. Mr.
Mullen. Mr. Mullen votes I. Mr. Lansman.
Mr. Lansman votes I. Miss Mlullen. Miss
Mlullen votes I. Mr. Guthrie. Mr.
Guthrie votes I.
>> Does anyone seek recognition? How's Mr.
Baruckus recorded?
>> Mr. Bill Rockus is not recorded.
>> I.
>> Mr. Bill Rockus votes I.
>> Anyone else seeking recognition? Seeing
none, the clerk will report.
Did Troy get recorded? I guess he must.
>> Mr. Chairman, on that vote there were 41
eyes and zero nos.
>> The eyes have it and the bill is
adopted. And I want to thank everyone
between the hearing right I mean the
markup right before our August work
period and today we've done a
substantial lot of bipartisan work and
so our works to get it across the floor.
So we really appreciate everybody's hard
work and hard effort and without
objection staff is authorized to make
technical and conformity changes to the
legislation approved by the committee
today. So ordered and without objection
the committee stands adjourned.
Excellent.